Sziasztok! Nemrég fejeztem be a
beszélgetést Csaladénessel, aki
szakértője a gépi tanulásnak és a
mesterséges intelligenciának. Több
egyetemen oktat, és rengeteg mindenben
vett részt. Többek között a székely
détának az alapítója. Vele beszélgettünk
az oktatásról, az AI-ról, a jövőről,
hogy hogyan tud egy tanár megújulni, és
milyen kvalitásokra van szüksége a
következő generációnak ahhoz, hogy
sikeres tudjon lenni ebben az új
korszakban.
Gyere, mutatkozz be nekünk, Dénes.
>> Kicsit vezess körbe az akadémiai
utadon, kezdve tegyük fel a Márton Áron
gimnáziummal,
hogy ott miután, érettségi után mi
történt veled?
>> Akárcsak te, azt hiszem, te egy évvel
fölöttem, vagy kettővel talán fölöttem
jártál a Mártanáromban. Én azután
elmentem egy kicsit furcsa történet ez.
Én nem voltam igazán, én néha voltam én
ilyen matek versenyeken, ami ugye a
Mártanáromban a a sláger volt. Talán te
is voltál egy egy jó páron.
Az én nem csak nem csak matek
versenyekre szerettem járni, hanem én
elmentem fizika versenyre is, én
elmentem kémiaversenyre, még
földrajzversenyre és még nyelvi
versenyre is. És
az egész környezetem azt próbálta nekem
mondani, hogy a márban volt egy olyan
kifejezés, hogy valamire rá kell állni,
és akkor azt kell csinálni. És akkor én
megfogadtam, hogy akkor én ennek
pontosan az ellentét próbálom minél
jobban, hát talán több-kevesebb sikerrel
végezni. Úgyhogy eléggé nyitott voltam
abból a szempontból, hogy hogy milyen
irányba haladjak. Konkrétan a fizikát és
a földrajzot szerettem talán talán a
legjobban. Ezt a földrajzot azt mai
napig inkább gyakorlatba ültetve
próbálom próbálom gyakorolni
utazgatással. Ö de talán a fizikától nem
vagyok annyira messze, mert
ö most, hogyha úgy mondjuk, hogy talán
kicsit mérnöki és kicsit ilyen adatos,
matekes részen mozog mozgokat, hát végül
is a fizika lesz az, amelyik összeköti
ezt a két területet. Úgyhogy
én nagyon sokat jártam Bukaresbe a
azért, mert japán kardivással Kendovval
foglalkoztam és akkor a min havonta volt
a a nemzeti válogatottnak volt egy ilyen
összegyűlése, ahol közösen edzettünk és
akkor én a a középiskolám nagy részében,
tehát ilyen 9en osztálytól a középiskola
végéig, majdnem minden hónapban péntek
este felültem a vonatra, és szomb vagy
vasárnap délután pedig visszajöttem.
Bokerespől és ez a k 90-es évek vége,
valóban 2000-es évek eleje az
Székelyföldön Bukarásnek a megítélése az
hát mondhatjuk azt, hogy kéliű volt, de
valójában negatív volt, tehát nem igazán
örventek annak az emberek, hogy így
sétafikáltam Bukaresbe.
>> Elemén nagyon szerettem Bukaresbe járni.
Nyilván segíthet abban, hogy mondjuk
megtanultam jobban beszélni románul,
mondjuk egyszer volt egy olyan, hogy
felhívtam, hogy foglaljak szállást és
kérdezték, hogy akkor hány hány
éjszakára kellene dopsz vagy train
nopsz? És mondom nekik, hogy hát unopt.
És akkor mondta erre a csávó, hogy Jezdi
Nargita mondom, hát igen, igen, hát nem
hallottad idáig még.
Úgyhogy
a később aztán így a így a mondjuk ugye
a 20-as éveim végén, 30-as éveim elején
így rájöttem, hogy
nagyon-nagyon sokat tudnánk tanulni a a
bukarestieknek
a hát mondhatjuk azt, hogy leszarom ming
mentalitásul, de inkább ez a ez a ez a
laza nyugodtságáról, ahogy kezelik a
ahogy kezelik a dolgokat, itt itt
hajlamosak vagyunk mindenre ráfeszülni.
És akkor én később aztán reflektával
rájöttem, hogy nekem az tetszett, hogy
egyszer csak megérkeztem vonattal
pénteken este 10-kor, és nem igazán volt
szállásom, és akkor felhívtam az akkori
válogatottoknak az edzőjét, és ő ő már
úgy ráérzett, hogy most jön a gyerkőc,
és valószínűleg nincsen szállása, és már
úgy úgy várt, hogy és akkor hol fogsz
aludni? Hát mondom, azt nem tudom, na
nem baj, gyere, győz velem, és akkor nem
tudom, hozzáv saját magához. Nyilván ez
itt is megtörténne, de úgy úgy úgy
könnyebben, úgy olyan olyan fluidabban
ment minden. Na, úgyhogy ennek ennek
margóján én én gondolkoztam azon, hogy
elmegyek Bukaresbe egyetemre,
kifejezetten fizikai egyetemre.
Aztán végül
úgy történt a
szüleim életpályáját követve, hogy
Kolozsvárra mentem a Műszakegyetemre
villamos karra, azt nagyon szerettem.
Ott
valjában már a második évről kezdtünk
kutatással foglalkozni. Meg nagyon fura
volt, de én már akkor valójában ilyen
neurális hálóknak a modellezésével
kezdtem foglalkozni. Ugye ez 2007-ben
vagy 2008-ban, ami amikor még nem volt
egyáltalán hype, és nagyon nehézkes
volt. Nem volt se Pythonban modul,
matlabban kellett összefaricskálni
ezeket a dolgokat. Nagyon nehéz volt,
de én ezt nagyon szerettem. És akkor
utána a villames mérnöki után
én gondolkoztam azon, hogy menjek
messzebbre.
Nem főtétlen,
Európába is jelentkeztem néhány helyre.
Kifejezetten
nem újra nekem nem volt ilyen, hogy most
én pont ezt szeretném csinálni, hanem
úgy néztem, hogy mik az érdekes
programok. Európában jelentkeztem néhány
űrkutatásos képzésre. Na most Európában
ugye az űrkutatás az nagyrészt francia
területen van,
az Airbas és Tulus köré koncentrálódik.
Úgyhogy az egyetem során megpróbál, most
se tudok franciául, de sok kurzusra
jártam az egyetem során, ahol próbáltak
megtanítani franciául azért, hogy a
Tuluzi Egyetemen menjek el ürkotalási
képzésre. Aztán felvettek, de végül
adtak valamit csak ösztöndíjat, de nem
tudtak annyi ösztöndíjat adni, hogy az
nekem kijöjjön, és nem akartam a
szüleimet rávenni arra, hogy ezt ezt
vinazírozzák nyilván.
Úgyhogy én az Egyesült Orbán
Emirátusokba kötöttem ki, akkoriban
nagyon nagy divat volt az, hogy neves
amerikai egyetemek ilyen ilyen szatellit
kampuszokat működtettek, mondjuk
Katarban, vagy Dubában vagy Abu Dabiban.
Én én pont Abu Dabiba mentem. a a
bostoni MIT-nak egy ilyen egy ilyen
szatellit kampuszára,
és ott elvégeztem a mesterimet. Aztán
pedig a
a mester is az ilyen ilyen research
masters volt, ilyen két éves kutatási
mester, és akkor meggyőzött a tanárom,
hogy maradjak ott még további három évet
és akkor végeztem ott egy PhD-st PhD-t
is. Azt már inkább ilyen ilyen Boston és
Abu Dhabi közötti ingázással. Na most az
első az
az komplex rendszerek modellezésében
volt. Ilyen agent based modelling meg
system dynamics modelling.
Tehát folyamat folyamat modellezés. És a
második az az már az már inkább inkább
adatvizualizációban kifejezetten
komplex rendszereknek az én választott
rendszerem, de az csak egy példarendszer
volt, az a az a globális fosszilis
tüzelő anyag kereskedelem volt, tehát a
a olaj, szén és földgáznak a
kereskedelme. Akkor itt van 200 játékos,
majdnem mindenki mindenkivel, egymással
kereskedik. És akkor hogyan lehet ezt a
200 pontos hálózatot, amit hogyha
felnagyítunk élekre, akkor már van benne
mondjuk 40000 él. Hogyan lehet ezt úgy
vizualizálni, hogy értelmehető legyen,
>> egy képernyőre ráférjen? Igen. Úgyhogy
én nagyrészt autóidakta módon kezdtem
tanulni az adatvizualizációt ott, amit
talán Székelyföldön később főleg ezt az
oldalamat ismerték meg az emberek.
És akkor utána Angliába elmentem
senkinek nem ajánlva, pozdok nélkül
elmentem
tanáriállásba.
Akkor az egy picit olyan nehéz volt,
mert ugye egyszerre ugye az egyetemi
tanárnál ott egyszerre kell
adminisztrációval foglalkozni, kurzust
tartani, de még nincsen annyi
publikációd, hogy legitimizálva legyél,
úgyhogy publikálni is kellene.
>> Tehát már a doktorim megvolt, gondolom
akkor már három publikációd minimum
volt.
>> Hát igen, volt a doktorim, és akkor volt
pontosan, ahogy mondod, volt három vagy
négy publikációm, és akkor az alapján az
alapján mentem én a Lenkesti egyetem be
tan egyetemre tanítani.
mér a mérnöki karnál, és a mai napig ott
hát ilyen fizikával kapcsolatos
tantárgyakat tanítok. Nem szeretem
egyébként annyira mérni ki tudományokat,
aztán ugye később egyre inkább
átnyargaltam az adattudomány fele.
>> Jelen pillanatban hány publikációdal, ha
jól értettem, hogy 20 körül tartasz? Ú,
nem tudom ezt olyasmi. Igen.
>> Tehát, hogy ha most én
>> megnézzük a Google Scholert, akkor ott
>> ha ha most azt azt nézem, hogy
körülbelül három publikáció kell egy
doktorihoz, akkor ezt ezt úgy is
felfoghatom, minthogyha ilyen hat-hét
doktorit összegyűjtöttél volna. Nem, ez
egyáltalán nem úgy van, mert
hát hogy mondjam ezt szépen, meg hogy ne
ne csapjon vissza az ost vége.
Annak ellenére, hogy
mondjuk úgy egy
egy egy jó egyetemen tanítok én
Angliában, én nem föltétlenül
tekintek úgy saját magamra, mint egy
mint egy jó kutató. Egy egy kicsit
zsivány vagyok én ahhoz, hogy jó jó
kutató legyek, mert amikor én elkezdem
írni a cikkemet, akkor közben eszembe
jut három érdekes ötlet, amit ezzel
párhuzamosan el fogok kezdeni, és akkor
lehet, hogy ebből a ebből a kohortból
lehet, hogy pont a publikáció lesz az,
amik befejeződik, de van egy nem nulla
esélye annak, hogy egy másik másik
érdekes ötlet lesz az. És akkor
valában most próbálok majdnem 50-50%-ban
vagy full time azzal zsonglőrködni, hogy
adatvizualizációs tanácsadással és
adatelemzési tanácsadással foglalkozak
fullt cégeknek. Főleg
főleg a londoni Cityben
szoktam mindenféle ilyen dashboardot.
kábé olyan, mint amikor a mint amikor a
a van ez a a az archetipikus
tőzsdei trader, amelyek előtt van nyolc
képernyő, és akkor hogyan lehet azt a
nyolc képernyőt úgy megtervezni, hogy ő
tényleg tudjon egy informált döntést
döntést hozni. Na most például most
ilyen az utóbbi két évben ilyen trading
dashboardok összerakásával foglalkoztam
>> főleg energiaszektorban tevéken
tevékenykedő kereskedő cégeknek. Ö és
úgy egyre inkább kezdett szürkülni az
akadémiai világ ezzel ö miután erre
egyre jobban rákezdtem állni. Nem azért,
mert nem szeretem az akadémiát, hanem
azért, mert úgy érzem, hogy ebben a
témában, a gépi tanulásban az akadémiai
világ túl lassú.
hogyha hogyha igazi és hogyha megnézed
ezt a szektort, hogyha igazi újásra
vágysz, akkor akkor még a legjobb
kutatók is elmennek a metához, vagy
elmennek az Open AIoz, vagy elmennek az
X-hez,
és
az akadémiában már csak egy
nagyon-nagyon nagyon-nagyon nís
feladatokkal lehet foglalkozni, ami
nyilván lehet, meg vannak ismerőseim,
akik ezt az utat választották és és
próbálják, de annak az
energiabefektetése nekem meg
tehát szerintem én túl vagyok, hogy
annyit annyit annyit befektessek azt a
15 éves energiabefektetés úgy gondolom,
hogy azt az időt el tudnám érdekesebb
területen
tölteni. Meg nyilván nagy az átfolyás,
azért nagyon sokat merítek abból, amit a
tanácsad munkám során végzek abban, hogy
hogyan tudom azt visszaforgatni a az
akadémiába.
Igen. Tehát akkor van egy erős akadémiai
háttered egy zsivány jellemmel, és most
a biznisvilágba is kezdtél belekóstolni,
és egyre inkább vonz ez a tanácsadási
rész.
Tehát van egy oktatói háttered, és
lényegében azért is beszélgetünk most
egymással, mert gépi tanulást oktatsz és
és használod és és érzed most ennek a a
ahogy fogalmaztál vadnyugati hangulatnak
a a lényegét. Ö kicsit beszélgessünk
magáról az oktatásról. Szerinted hogyan
fogja átalakítani az AI az oktatást?
>> Na igen, azt elmondtam, hogy annak
ellenére, hogy én a a Lenkeszt egyetemen
a mérnöki karon vagyok ezzel ezzel
párhuzamosan a Bristoli egyetemen ott
tanítok kifejezetten bevezetést
géptanulásba. És én én próbálok vigyázni
a kifejezéseimmel, mert ugye itt
általában a mesterséges intelligencia
meg a gépi tanulás, meg az AI meg minden
így össze szoktak folyni a kifejezések.
Ön általában a gépitanulás kifejezést
szoktam használni azért, hogy legyen
egyértelmű, hogy itt specifikus
feladatoknak a gépek által való
megoldásáról van szó, és nem ez a nem ez
a terminátor típusú átveszik a gépek a
hatalmat fölöttünk, amit általában a
mesterséges intelligencia kifejezéshez
szoktak inkább társtani az emberek. Na
de ott ott foglalkozok adatvizualizáció
és és képtanulás oktatással. És akkor
azt a kurzust ö hát ugye érdekes, vagy
vagy gyakoribb lenne azt mondani, hogy
azt próbáltam áthozni Romániába, de
egyáltalán nem így volt, hanem még
azelőtt én a a közgázon, Kolozsváron a
Bólyain, a közgázon ott elkezdtem egy
adatvizualizációs kurzust, amit aztán
később kiterjesztettünk egy ott úgy
hívjuk pont, hogy bevezetés a
mesterséges intelligenciába kurzussal,
és azt a tapasztalatomat vittem
valójában Brisolba, úgyhogy igen, ezt
ezt próbálom oktatni.
Hát, hogy mennyire fogja ez átformálni
az oktatást.
Teljesen őszintén a azt tudom mondani,
hogy szerintem
mindig nehéz ezt mond, mint a fúziós
energiából, hogy most 20 év múlva vagy
30 év múlva, mindegy, néhány évtized
múlva nem lesz egyetem szerintem a
mesterséges intelligencia miatt és most
nem kell azért úgy meglepődni, vagy ez
és nem föltétlen gondolom ezt egy
negatív dolognak, hanem az egyetemek
nagyon át kell alakuljanak, és szerintem
át is fognak alakulni ilyen ilyen
mikrépesítésekké.
És akkor jön egy jön egy valaki, akinek
van mondjuk egy napelem
tervező cége, akkor ő azt fogja mondani,
nekem olyan szakemberek kellenek, akik
értenek egy kicsit a cashfowhoz, értenek
egy kicsit a mondjuk az
akkumulátorokhoz, és akkor ezt így össze
fogják legózni a skilleket. Tehát
jelenleg egy óriási nagy silózódás van.
Ez Erdélyben talán sokkal nyilvánvalóbb,
mint mint például Angliában vagy vagy
Amerikában talán, akik a amit még egy
picit jobban ismerek a hátterét.
Úgyhogy az fog az fog történni
szerintem, hogy az ilyen mikro skilleket
kell majd összelegózzuk, és ezek a
mikroskillek
mindig egy mesterséges intelligencia
által lesznek nekünk
hát nem mondom, hogy tanítva, de a a a
törzse a szilabusznak az azt
valószínűleg egy mesterséges
intelligencia fogja összerakni. És a
tanári szakma az az valójában a kurátor
lesz, hogy hogyan legózzuk össze ezeket
a dolgokat, és hogyan személyre Szabva
én Szabolsnak hogy tudok egy egy
bizonyos képzést összerakni. Lehet, hogy
hozok egy datacempes kurzust, lehet,
hogy hozok egy oxfordos kurzust, lehet,
hogy hozok egy szapienciás kurzust, és
akkor azokat össze összegyűlom.
>> Tehát olyan, mint egy személyjedző
gyakorlatilag
>> abszolút olyan lesz. Tehát ilyen
ez is ugye ez volt a trend egy időben,
hogy personalize everything az az
oktatás is ilyen teljesen teljesen
személyre szabott lesz. Ö tudom, hogy
hosszú válaszokat adok, de hadd hadd
hadd tegyem ezt még hozzá, hogy a
például a kolozsvári kurzusaimon
annyira tehát én nem titok, hogy azt úgy
használom, mint egy műhely, de annyira
fluidan próbálom ezt az egészet kezelni,
hogy mikor 2020
2022-ben kijött a a chatpt-nek, a 3.5-ös
5-ös GPT-nek a a felhasználó felülete,
akkor a akkor fél év közben
megváltoztattuk és azt mondtuk, hogy ez
most annyira
annyira merőben megváltoztat mindent,
hogy eddig amiket tanultunk, úgy majdnem
eldobjuk. És most én úgy tartom például
az adatvizualizáció, vagy elkerén három
év, de úgy tartom az adatvizualizáció és
a mesterséges intelligenciával való
bevezetés kurzust, hogy hogy nem írnak
ők kódot. Tehát ők nem írnak se
JavaScript kódot, nem írnak, se Python
kódot nem írnak, hanem megpróbáljuk
különböző mesterséges intelligencia
agentekkel ezt a feladatot elvégeztetni.
És akkor nekem ez egy nagyon pozitív
vissza. Persze vannak van, aki azt fogja
mondani, hogy hű hát akkor ez most mi az
egyetem, most nem tanulnak semmit, de ez
egy óriási pozitív visszajelzés volt
nekem.
sokkal érdekesebb projekteket tudtak
összerakni ugyanabban az időben. És
lehet azt mondani, hogy hát igen, mert
úgy is az AI írta a projektet, de nem
úgy van, mert tényleg értették azt, hogy
hogyan volt összerakva. És ez szerintem
azért volt, mert nekem mint oktatónak
több időm és terem volt arra, hogy
kifejezetten például az adatvizualizáció
kurzuson az elvekről beszéljünk, hogyan
kell kommunikálni valamit, hogyan
válassztjuk meg a színeket, hogyan
választjuk meg az elhelyezéseket, és
aztán majd az, hogy milyen eszközben,
milyen témában kell megírni, azt majd az
A elvégzi. Tehát így a a ki munkát most
nagyon jó az é elvégezni. Tehát
kevesebbet foglalkoznak a JavaScriptnek
a szintaxisával, és többet foglalkoznak
a a lényegével, hogy mit vizualizálnak
és miért.
>> Igen. Az alkalmazással. És ez szerintem
egy egy óriási pozitív pozitív dolog. De
ezt, hogyha továbbvetítjük, akkor ez az
alkalmazás ez igen van annak a veszélye,
hogy oda oda odáig fog kerülni, hogy
kiváltja magát a a az embert. És ugye
erről sokan sokan félnek tőle, vagy
sokan beszélnek róla. Igen. Hát a a
látok most feszültségnek, az az, hogy a
az oktatási rendszerünk azt szokta meg,
hogy olyan feladatokat kérnek, ami
amelyek mérhetőek a diákoktól, és az
eredményt, amit beszolgáltatnak úgymond
a diákok, azokat mérjük. Viszont ebben a
pillanatban teljesen szétzúzza a mérési
rendszerünket az, hogy hogy mesterséges
intelligenciát tudnak használni. Tehát
bizonyos szempontból meg kell újuljon
maga a pontozási rendszerünk, vagy
egyáltalán hogyan is állunk a diákokhoz.
Te ezt hogyan oldod meg a te
kurzusaidon?
>> Ez a jelenlegi
angliai felsőoktatásban a legközpontibb
kérdés, hogy covid alatt volt egy olyan
szerintem pozitív irányba való
elmozdulás, hogy kezdtek hagyni például
online vizsgákat. Azelőtt ugye a az
angliai oktatási rendszer az egy kicsit
ilyen ilyen rigidebb és megindokolják
azzal ugye, hogy ezt mi 500 éve
csináljuk, valah valamit jól csináltunk
és ezt ezt teljesen meg lehet érteni, de
minden ilyen nagyon a vizsgák azok élő
élőben voltak papíron. akkor egy picit
hagyták, hogy legyenek online vizsgák a
covid alatt, mert másképp nem volt
lehetséges.
És
én amúgy is online vizsgát használtam
volna mindig, úgyhogy ennek én nagyon
örventem, mert az online vizsgában,
amikor ugye hát itt szinonmával lehet
használni azt, hogy a nyitott könyves
vizsga az online vizsga,
sokkal nehezebb a tanárnak online
vizsgát készíteni, ezért nem szeretik
szerintem, mert olyan feladatot kell
összerakni, ami ami inkább a magára a
gondolkodásra, erre a reasoningre
helyezi a hangsúlyt, mert ott a
feladatot meg kell oldani minden ilyen
rendelkezésedre álló eszközökkel. Tehát
egy nehezebb, egy összetettebb
feladatot, egy specifikusabb feladatot
ennek a kurzusnak a tananagjára
specifikusabban épülő feladatot kell
összerakni és egy kicsit nyitottabb kell
egy nem egy egy számot kell várni
válasznak, hanem egy indoklást, ugye, és
az nyilván nehezebb összerakni, nehezebb
értékelni, több munkával jár a a tanár
részéről,
>> meg meg a meg gyakorlatilag nem is tudod
ellenőrizni, hogy csalt-e vagy nem nem
is tudom, mit jelent a csalás
egyáltalán.
Így nem is érdekel, tehát irreleváns
lesz az, hogy az h az, hogy csalt-e
abban egészen addig, amíg kezd használni
egy mesterséges
intelligenciaasszisztensst, ugye, mert
hogyha hogyha egy tényleg saját magától
összerakta volna azt a azt a a
gondolkodási keretet, hogy ő úgy
gondolja, hogy ez most ez pozitív vagy
negatív, vagy mit tudom én, akkor az úgy
egészen jó volt. Na de most miután
megjelentek a mesterséges intelligencia
asszisztensek, ezeket a típusú vizsgákat
meg tudják íratni a a gyerkőcsök. Sok és
persze vannak próbálkoznak így, hogy
most detektáljuk, hogy ez AI-jal írt
válasz-e, de az csak olyan, hogy egy
másik modellt ellenőriztetünk ezzel a
modellel. Tehát az nem egy igazán igazán
használható dolog. Úgyhogy a az angli
egyetemek például azt a azt az irányt
képviselik, hogy akkor akkor vissza
vissza a kőkorszakban nincsenek online
vizsgák azért, mert AI-t fognak
használni. AI-t nem használjunk, nem
támogatjuk, ez egy rossz irány, csak
kézzel írott
papíron élő emberes vizsgák vizsgák
vannak, ami szerintem
egy egy hirtelen
rövid távon talán működő reakció erre
erre a helyzetre. De hosszú távon
elkerülhetetlen lesz az még
Székelyföldön is, hogy különböző
algoritmusok által elvégzett feladatokat
látunk körülöttünk, és lesznek emberek
által elvégzett feladatok. Ebben együtt
kell élni. Úgyhogy minél hamarabb
tudnánk adaptálni. Nincsen válaszom,
hogy most például hogy tudnánk a a a
rendőr rendőr
ködését megoldani a vizsgáknak. Ez egy
nehéz feladat, de én úgy gondolom, hogy
inkább abba az irányba kellene néznünk,
hogy hogyan tudjunk, hogyan tudunk az
AI-al együtt élni akkor és ezek az
algoritmusok se. Egy idő után, hogyha
elég sokat interakcionálsz velük, akkor
úgy rájössz, hogy hol vannak a
limitációik, miket miket, hogy kell
olyat kérdezni, amire nem tudja a
választ. Most nyilván ez minden
generációval jobb lesz.
De talán majd beszélhetünk arról, hogy
hogy néz ki egy nagy nyelvi modell, és
akkor hol lehet kiszúrni az ő az
>> Igen. Még talán egy gondolatot ehhez
hozzászúrnék, hogy talán bizonyos
szempontból a jegy maga irreleváns lesz.
Ugye ahogy mondtad, bizonyos cégek, ha
meghirdettek egy pozíciót és kérnek majd
különböző tantárgyakat,
gyakorlatilag most hány perc alatt lehet
leellenőrizni azt, hogy valaki beszél-e
angolul? Hány perc alatt lehet
leellenőrizni, hogy valaki ért-e adott
nethez, vagy Pythonhoz, vagy hogy
tudja-e használni? Tehát ezek ezek
nagyon-nagyon gyorsan leellenőrizhető
dolgok, hogyha valakit behívsz és
konkrétan elkezd kérdezgetni.
>> Úgyhogy úgyhogy lehet, hogy ilyen
szempontból mindegy, és az is, hogy hogy
egyetemet végez-e valaki vagy nem. Ez is
most már kezdett egyre nem annyira
fontossá válni. Szerintem inkább csak
arról szól, hogyha valaki elvégezett
egyetemet, az képes volt három évig
koncentráltan figyelni valamire és
felelősséget vállalni, a végén pedig
vizsgázni. erről szól, mert maga a
tudás, amit összeszedett, az nem annyira
fontos pár év múlva, egy évtized múlva,
mert mit számít azz, hogy mit tanultam?
Nem tudom, az nem tudom, te végeztél-e
ilyen ECDL vizsgát, de
>> akkor még valaki azt gondolhatta, hogy
ennek lesz egy egy
>> egy előnye, hogy lesz rendelkezek ECDL
diplomával, de rendesen én szégyelném
beírni a címébe, hogy valakinek ECDL
diplomája van, mert ez ez már nem
lényeg. És ennyire gyorsan halad a
világunk,
a a dolgok gyorsan változnak, és és kár
egy diplomával a tudásunkat
garantálni.
Valahogy van egy ilyen kép a fejemben.
Most kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre,
hogy
ezt amúgy színek mondta, Simon Színek,
nem tudom, hogy ismered, nagyon tetszett
az a gondolata, hogy a az oktatási
rendszerünk nagyon ráfókuszált az
eredményekre.
>> Ühüm. És valójában az eredmények egy
sokkal fontosabb dolgot takartak el
eddig, a folyamatot, mert a folyamat az
a az az, amin végig kell menjen a diák
ahhoz, hogy megértse és és dolgozzon
vele és izzadjon vele azzal a azzal a
problémával, mire a végére érs el tudta
érni azt az eredményt, addig addig
megtanult valamit. Hogyha most egyből
kiköpi a mesterséges intelligencia
nekünk azt az eredményt, akkor valójában
leadja, és túljutott azon a nehézségen
és nem tanult semmit. És akkor juhú, még
egy vizsga, és nem tanultam semmit. És
valójában a folyamat az, ami a fontos
számunkra, hogy valahogy a fejemben van
egy ilyen kép, mintogyha lenne minden
nap 100 kreditünk, amit tanulással annyi
kapacitásunk van, hogy megtanuljunk
valami újat. És hogyha ilyen-olyan
mókuskodással kikerüljük a tanulást, és
az eredményt próbáljuk elérni, akkor és
nem költöttük el a 100 kreditünket,
tegyük csak 60-at belőle, vagy csak
20-at, akkor a holnapi napra-et kapunk.
kicsit olyan, mint a a az okos órán a a
lépésszámláló, hogy adaptálódik a a a
célunkhoz, de viszont, hogyha tudatosan
önmagunkért tanulunk, tehát az a mi
belső és ilyen szempontból belső
fegyelem kell ehhez, az a mi belső
vágyunk, hogy elköltsük minden egyes nap
a 100 kreditet, akkor lehet holnap
101-et fogok kapni, és utána és 102-t.
Ez egy nagyon jó, nagyon jó meglátás
szerintem a, tehát meg kell különböztet,
meg kell különböztessük a megoldást és a
megértést. neked a nagy nyelvi modell a
megoldást azonnal felajánlja, de nem
föltétlenül biztos, hogy az embereknek
arra van szüksége. Az embereknek inkább
a megértés folyamatára van szüksége.
Csak úgy tudja ugye a meglévő tudáshoz
csak úgy tudjuk hozzákapcsolni az új az
új élményeket, hogyha nem csak egy
ponton egy
kapcsolódási élménnyel, hanem több
ponton be tudjuk hálózni. És ezért
felejted el ugye azt, amikor
még csináltunk ilyet azért a Marciban,
hogy be kellett magoljuk a vizsgára ezt
ezt vagy azt. És akkor az ugye egy hét
múlva elfelejtődik, mert nem kapcsolódik
elég sok rövid távú memóriába bepakoltuk
és nem kezen.
És akkor nagyon sok esetben ugye neked a
amikor a mesterséges intelligencia
modell megmondja neked a választ, akkor
azt úgy használod, meg írt nekem például
a múltkor nem tudom 40000 sor kódot és
működik. Most gőzöm sincs, hogy milyen
frameworköket használt.
És ez itt akkor egy nehéz kérdés, hogy
szükségünk van-e valójában megértésre.
És akkor itt szerintem nagyon attól fog
attól kezd függeni, hogy milyen típus,
milyen alkalmazás területén vagyunk,
milyen problémánk van.
>> Mondj egy olyan területet, ahol a
megértésre nincs szükség. Hát én
például, hogyha hogyha hogyha kell
csináljak egy egy dashboardot, és az át
kell adjon egy bizonyos információt,
akkor nem biztos nem biztos, hogy minden
szintű megértésre van szükség. hogyha én
értem, hogy ez a ez a vonaldiagram ennek
a bizonyos tőzsdeindexnek a változását
mutatja időben, és jól vannak összerakva
a tengelyek, és nem torzik, akkor én nem
föltétlenül kell értsem azt, hogy ő a a
amikor megírta a chatgét, vagy a cló ezt
a kódot a 40000 sorba, akkor milyen
frameworköket használt, és azok hogy
kötődnek egymáshoz. Kifejezetten akkor,
hogyha hogyha és általában van, hogyha
időnyomás van, és ezt ezt holnap be kell
mutassam. És akkor így én úgy érzem,
hogy folyamatosan, ahogy te mondtad ezt
a kredites rendszert, én úgy érzem, hogy
a minden egyes alkalommal, amikor a
amikor a cloudot használjuk, én például
kódírásra clódot szoktam használni,
akkor így így így így az adósságot így
növelem ezekkel a kreditekkel, hogy újra
megírtam 40000 soródot, újra nem tudom,
hogy egy része, egy része működik, aztán
majd egyszer egy nap visszamegyek és
akkor megtanulom. És akkor már annyien
aztán egyszer egy nap van, hogy már
érzem, hogy lenyom az adósság. És ez egy
ilyen, tehát majdnem ilyen akkora
mentális stresszt okoz, hogy hogy akkor
néha meg kell álljak, és akkor azt
mondom, hogy miket csináltam itt ezeket
ezeket meg meg kell nézni. Tehát
fruszáltak leszünk, hogy nem
>> program pont így vagyok, de erre kaptam
egy megoldást. Gyakorlatilag pont az,
hogy nem költöttem el azt a kreditet a
részleteinek a JavaScript frameworknek a
megértésére, de elköltöm másra. De el
kell költsem másra. Tehát, hogy valami
újat tanuljak aznap valami más
területen, mert megspórolta nekem azt,
hogy hogy de egy kicsit úgy vagyunk az
autóval is, hogy én nagyon hálás vagyok,
hogy nem kell a karburátorhoz értsek.
Nekem a a elég, hogyha a kormányt, és
most már automataváltós autót vezetek,
elég, hogyha a kormányt ismerem és
rendben, a picit butultam ezáltal, mert
még a édesapám és a az előttem levő
generáció úgy szétszedte a motorrot, és
rakta össze, hogy még utána működött. Én
ez erre már nem vagyok képes. És akkor
mondhatná valaki, hogy akkor kevesebb
vagyok, mint az elődeim, de legyek több
más területen, mert ha nem vagyok több
más területen, akkor tényleg kevesebb
vagyok. Akkor kevésbé vagyok reziliens,
kevésbé vagyok türelmes, kevésbé vagyok
művelt, mint az előttem levő generáció,
aki akinek hatalmas lexikális tudása
volt. És számomra nem, tehát én én nekem
nincs akkora lexikális tudásom, mint
édesapámnak, amilyen volt. Viszont más
területen van sokkal több tapasztalatom.
Például keresni jobban tudok, mint az
előttem levő generáció.
>> Pont pont e pont erre akartam
reflektálni, hogy például
ugye az Open AI-nak a vezetője Szem
Altman, akit egyébként nem szeretek
azért, mert az Open AI-ból a
nonprofitból for profit céget csinált.
>> És Ilon Maskot szeretett?
>> Őt se szeretem egyébként. Tudod kit
szeretek? Iliásévert, aki volt a a az
Open AI alapításakor. Ilon Musk volt a
pénz, de Iliasckével volt az agy. És
egyébként az későbbin openos balhék is
azért voltak, mert a az az irány, amit
Iliackéver képvisel, ez a ugye a
mindegyik
szilikonvölgyi cégnek mindegyiknek az a
célja, hogy AGI, artificial general
intelligence, tehát általános
mesterséges intelligenciát végezzenek,
az az, hogy jelenleg a ezek a nagy
nyelvi modellek nagyon jól elvégeznek
egy specifikus feladatot, de nem tudnak
a feladatok között átmenni, vagy
ugrálni, vagy csak nagyon nehezen,
hogyha Ha van neked egy gyakran
hozzákevel az példának, hogyha most
ketten sakkozunk, hogyha te egy
algoritmus vagy, akkor nyilván
különösebb erőfesztés nélkül megversz
engem, de hogyha meglökjük az asztalt és
leesnek a figurák a földre, akkor az
ember az felveszi az a táblát, és
visszateszi a figurákat, és az
algoritmus ez így legyen blue screen of
death. Nem tudja, hogy most mi történt.
Na és nagyon veszélyes, ugye, tehát itt
két irány vissza kell az oktatás, de ezt
muszáj elmondjam, mert egy ilyen rövid
kitérének, hogy a az általános
mesterséges intelligenciát hogyan
fejlesztjük, az van ez a teljesen
minden minden ilyen stoppot, amit be
szeretnénk építeni. Tehát hogyha félünk
tőle, hogyha tényleg utána majd valami
veszélyes dolog lesz, akkor azt az
építés során el kell képzeljük, hogy mi
romolhat el, és azokat a stopokat bele
kell építsük. Vagy pedig a másik
megközelítés az az, hogy
minél több erőforrást adjunk neki, minél
jobban menjen, aztán majd később később,
hogyha lesz valami baj, akkor majt
próbáljuk kezelni. És hát az cuckével ő
ő ő pontosan ezt a biztonságos, és ő úgy
ő úgy szokta megfogalmazni, hogy
explainable AI, tehát megmagyarázható
mesterséges intelligencia, mindenképpen
ezt a vonalat követi, a Szem Altman
pedig ő inkább a dollárjeleket próbálja
üldözni. Na mindegy. Szematma mondta,
hogy a ugye a a milleni a a
milleniális generáció, talán a mi
generációnk valamilyen szinten.
Mi keresésre használjuk a mesterséges
intelligenciát. A talán a a az a Z
generáció már problémam megoldásra,
tehát ők már próbálják összekötni
eszközökkel. És az alfa generáció azok
ugye ilyen teljesen operációs
rendszernek használják. mindent azzal
próbálnak. Az első nem a nem a Google
vagy a az adott választott keresőjük
lesz az első lépés, hanem a chatpt lesz
az első pont. Na most nyilván erről
erről majd biztos bele vannak tárazva
neked a kérdések, hogy ez ez mennyire
veszélyes lehet, milyen milyen rejtett
milyen rejtett kiskapuk vannak itt, hogy
egy
valaki által épített modellt használjál,
mint a a mindent tudó mindent tudó kő,
mint a bölcsek köve a Harry Potterben. Ö
de talán nem adunk nekik elég kreditet.
És én ezt nagyon látom a a diákok során,
akit oktatok Kolosváron, jönnek a 19
éves, 20 éves diákok, akiknek
mit tudom én, kulcsra zárt biznisze van,
és már már egy nagyobb bevételi
forrással rendelkezik, mint a szülője.
És mondjuk az a biznis az egy az egy
Discord bot. A a amit pontosan mondott,
hogy olyan területek jöttek létre a
és szerintem nem a köz nem a mesterséges
intelligencia, hanem a közösségi
médiának a fejlődése által az utóbbi 20
évben, amire egyáltalán nem gondoltunk
úgy, hogy és ezt gyakran mondják, ugye
úgy megy a gyerkőc egyetemre, hogy olyan
munkahely lesz, ami még az nem létezik.
Most szerintem nem így van, legalábbis
Erdében biztos nem. Ö de azért
nagyon-nagyon pozitív nekem a
megítélésem ö arról, hogy hogyan
találják fel a a gyerkőcök magukat. És
tényleg olyan nem kellők értsék, hogy
hogy működik a karburátor, hogyha ő tud
építeni egy Discord botot, és azt élvezi
és van egy közösség, aki ezt értékeli,
hát akkor őt kell támogatni minél
jobban.
>> Hm. Szerintem
>> igen. Akkor beszéljünk egy kicsit a
veszélyekről, úgy ahogy mondtad, de nem
a a nem azt a triviális utat fogom
követni, ami hogy most jön a Terminátor
korszak, hanem
>> hanem számomra van egy dilemma, amit nem
tudtam még sehogy se feloldani, de
birkózok ezzel a kérdéssel és és
kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre. Az egyik
dolog, amit látok, az, hogy
az emberi
intelligencia, az IQ, az normál
eloszlást mutat. Ez egy haranggörőrbe,
és ahol ahol középen van a 100-as IQ, és
ki lehet számolni pontosan, hogy az
emberiségnek a hány százaléka van, hány
ikú körül.
És ez elég megdöbbentő és fájdalmas
statisztika. Nem tudok mit kezdeni vele,
hogy bizonyos emberek miért kapnak több
ikút, miért kapnak kevesebbet. E ez
tényleg ez egy az emberiség
tragédiájához hozzátartozik. Viszont az
IQ az egyik
egy egyik tényezője a sikernek.
Kimutathatóan látszik, hogy a magasabb
ikújú emberek sikeresebbek a gazdasági
világban, mint az alacsonyabb kújú
személyek. És ez nem meglepő valahol,
csak fájdalmas ezt ebben a toleráns
világban tudomásul venni. Ha szakítsalak
félbe.
Szerintem ami kimutatható az az, hogy
azok a módszerek, amiket használunk
jelenleg az IQ-nak a meghatározására,
azok vannak korrelációban azokkal a
módszerekkel, amiket használunk a
sikernek a megmérésére. Tehát itt muszáj
azt muszáj azt megcsillagozzuk, hogy a
mérési módszereink valószínűleg nem
tökéletesek egyik egyik irányba se.
Úgyhogy itt amikor a két hibázal-ot
összeszorozzuk egymással, akkor
valószínűleg az általános trendjeinkről
való megítélések tényleg nem tévednek,
de azért egy adott embernek, vagy még
talán egy kis, hogyha elég kics kicsi a
csoport, annak a sikerének a megítélése,
az nagyon nehezen mérhető szerintem a
jelenlegi módszerek.
>> Nehezen mérhető, de ha mérhető valami,
akkor ez a legstabilabb. Ezt akarom
mond.
>> Értem, értem, értem. Csak itt van egy
csillag. Szerintem
>> van egy csillag. De azt te is
tapasztaltad, hogy azok az emberek,
akiknek vág az esze, azok gyorsan
adaptálódnak minden környezetben, és és
van egy határozott előnyük ahhoz képest,
aki kicsit tompább.
És például az amerikai hadseregnél nem
vesznek fel senkit 83 ikó alatt.
>> Ühüm.
>> Pedig az amerikai hadsereg az egy ilyen
nagyon humán erőforrás, éhes
territórium. bárkit felvesznek, akit
csak felvehetnek, és egyszerűen arra
jöttek rá, hogy 83 IQ alatt nem tudnak
semmilyen olyan munkát adni neki, ami
ahol nem sérti meg magát, vagy tehát
fegyverekkel nem dolgoz. Még takarítani
sem takaríthat,
>> és a az emberiség 15%-a 83 IQ vagy
azalatt
azzal rendelkezik. Ez egy fájdalmas
statisztika, tényleg, mert mit kezdünk
ezekkel az emberekkel? Mi a mi
felelősségünk, akik akik 83 IQ fölött
vagyunk?
És az egyik gondolatom most a ezzel a
ezzel a robbanással, ezzel a vadnyugati
hangulattal, ami ami körbőveszi a
mesterséges intelligenciát, az az, hogy
az okos emberek még okosabbá válnak,
tehát hogy aránytalanul
produktívvá válnak, produktívabbá, és
egyre nagyobb lesz szerintem a belépési
küszöb, hogy igazán produktív legyen az,
amit csinálsz. Már egyre több IQra lesz
szükség, 8485. És csak úgy nő és nő ez a
százalék.
Tehát egyik oldalról most legyek én a
vészmadár, legyek én a az, aki azt az
oldalt képvisel, mert tudok megnyugtató
dolgokat is mondani, de inkább legyél te
az, aki aki megnyugtatsz engem ezzel
kapcsolatban, hogy mit kezdünk ezekkel
az emberekkel is. És való valójában
tényleg ez lesz, hogy
>> hát ez
perzben nyugodtan.
>> Valójában tényleg ez lesz, hogy egyre
nagyobb lesz a belépési küszöb ahhoz,
hogy bármilyen produktív dolgot tudják.
Most nem a fogyasztásról beszélek, mert
mert egyszerű tényleg az van, hogy egy
az a mesterséges intelligencia
leegyszerűsíti a fogyasztást. Sokkal
könnyebb lesz rendelni egy pizzát, mert
eddig egy honlapon vagy egy mobil
applikáción kellett bepötyögni valam,
vagy bementél, de most a mesterséges
intelligenciának, ahogy csak tudod,
elmondod, hogy éhes vagyok, és az
agenteken keresztül ki fogja hozni. Már
most kihozza, de el fog terjedni egy-két
éven belül, hogy ez lesz a a a hum így
fog működni. Igen, igen.
>> Az a baj, hogy ez egy annyira nehéz
kérdés, hogy nem
talán úgy érzem, hogy nem rendelkezünk,
nem tiszteljük eléggé a kérdést, hogyha
nem bontjuk ki teljesen. És ez ez oda
fog visszavezetni a a az egyik emberiség
etikai alapelvére, hogy akkor most
kommunizmust szeretnénk, vagy
kapitalizmust szeretnénk, mert a
kapitalizmusban ugyanez történik, hogy
azok a azok a szereplők, akiknek már
több, már nagyobb, tehetősebb gazdasági
ereje van, ők sokkal egyszerűbben fognak
továbbra is tőkéhez jutni, és azáltal,
hogy tőkéhez jutnak, még több még jobban
fogják, ugye még még több vagyonra
tesznek szert, még jobban fogják ezt
Paretto ev irányából, vagyis ParetOVnek
megfelelően egy szűk szükk kisebbség fog
méni
>> egyre inkább, de nem ilyen 2080-as
Paréto elv, hanem inkább ilyen 199-es
paré elv lesz lesz lesz az eloszlás.
Igen.
>> És
a mesterséges intelligencia esetében ez
abszolút így van. Tehát arról, amit én
az elejéről beszélgettem, ahhoz, hogy
valaki egyáltalán
ugye én én model kontext protokolról
beszéltem, de az, hogy valaki ezt tudja
használni, azért nagyon sok lépésen
keresztül kellett menni, hogy megértsük,
hogy ez tényleg hogyan lehet hasznos
számunkra. És ami még ami talán ami amit
a legutoljára mondtál, hogy a a
konszumerizmus szempontjából
leegyszerűsít a mesterséges
intelligencia, az talán az talán még
elszomorítóbb,
mert aki aki használni fogja ezt, az még
inkább abba a sarokba lesz terelve, hogy
még kevésbé dolgozzon, még kevésbé
fektessen be erőfeszítést.
holott az a az a mérnök, aki mondjuk azt
az applikációt fejlesztette, az akkor
inkább a másik irányba tolódik el. Ez
most szerintem ez nem egy nem egy nem is
egy technikai, nem egy mérnöki kérdés,
ez ez majdnem egy etikai kérdés.
hogy akkor
kellene kell szabályozzuk a mesterséges
intelligenciához való hozzáférést.
És ezt már nyilván erre nincsen válasz.
Szerintem egyértelmű válasz. Nagyon
nehezen lehet megvédeni egyik oldalt,
másik oldalt.
>> Hát meg egyáltalán praktikusan. Ez hogy
is hangzik? Hogy
>> egyáltalán praktikus? És akkor ezt én
ide visszadobnám, hogy
>> kell leszabályozzuk kell leszabályozzuk
a kereskedelmi aktivitást. Vannak
országok, vannak történelmi periódusok,
ahol ezt próbálták. Van, amelyik
pozitívan sült el, van amelyik negatívan
sült el. Mi emberekként szerintem még
egyelőre nem találtunk ki egy olyan
keretrendszert, ahol ezt meg tudnánk úgy
meg tudnánk úgy beszélni magunkkal, hogy
szerintünk ez jó. Ugye volt a ugye a nem
is ne is mondjunk kommunizmust, hanem
csak mondjuk, hogyha a közjavaknak a
megosztásáról beszélünk, hogyha csak
szocializmust mondunk, akkor hogyan
tudnánk ezt, tehát én praktikusan nem
látom, hogy hogyan tudjuk ezt
átfordítani a mesterséges
intelligenciára. hogyha én használok,
hogyha én én most összerakok például egy
egy chatbotot a hamnak, akkor hogyha
abból a a megrendelése a Hamnak
megnövekedik, akkor én ki kéne vessek
egy ilyen chatbot adót államként, hogyha
szeretném, hogy a társadalom laposabb
laposabb eloszlást képviseljen.
Ezt ezt nem érzem magam kompetensek,
hogy ebben mond mond mondjak valami
valami kézzelf foghatót. Pontosan azért,
mert ide szerintem egy
társadalmi, szociológiai háttér kellene
ahhoz, hogy egyáltalán megvizsgáljuk,
hogy mit jelentett ez kifejezetten
gazdasági
szekt szempontból nézve ezt ezt a
problémát. és a mesterséges
intelligencia az, ahogy mondtad, először
lesz gazdasági, de később át fog
fordulni ugye a saját a saját életed
kényelmesebb lesz, tehát a praktikus
feladatoknak a megoldására. És ez,
hogyha nekem lesz itthon egy robotom,
aki kitölti ezt a vizet, akkor én keves
akkor én mondjuk azt hát a vagy lustább
vagyok kitölteni magamnak a vizet, vagy
b közben végzek valamit, ami talán úgy
úgy saccolom meg, vagy úgy ítélem meg,
hogy ez egy magasabb később később több
bevételhez, de lehet a szellemi
bevételhez fog juttatni, ezért most nem
fogom kitölteni magamnak a vizet. Az,
hogy én eljussak arra a pontra, hogy a
robot nekem kitöltse a vizet, egyrészt
egy olyan házban kell laknom, ahol a
robot tud mozogni, meg kell vegyem azt a
robotot, és akkor nyilván ez nagyon
leszűkíti azt a azt az alkalmazás
területeket, amelyik ugye tehát még ahol
a személyes kényelem is
szerepelni fog. Úgyhogy
>> annyit annyit tudok mondani, hogy igen,
igen, ez így van. Egyre nagyobb egyre
nagyobb szakadékot fog kreálni a
mesterséges intelligencia. Nem igazán
tudjuk ezt szerintem még kezelni, de
kell, de azért, hogy a másik másik
oldalat is egy picit megemlítsem, azért
azért kell vigyázni arra, hogy
valójában a kapitalizmusból jöttek ki a
legnagyobb új társok, amik a
társadalmunkat előrevitték, és nem a
szocializmusból. Úgyhogy szerintem
jelenleg még kell hagyni azt, hogy azok,
akik hozzáféréssel rendelkeznek, minél
több, minél érdekesebb feladatot
végezzenek el.
Ez ez ez nagyon érdekes dinamika, hogy
pont behoztad a szocializmust ide és a
kapitalizmust olyan, mintogyha kéne
választani a kettő között. Igen.
>> Viszont valójában együtt van a kettő,
együtt működik, mert van egy ha egy
országban kapitalizmus van, van egy erős
szociális baloldal, amelyik folyamatosan
ellenpólust tart
>> és már egyből kezd felhangzani a UBI-nak
ez a universal basic income, vagy az
egységes alapjövedelem, ami a a ami
gyakorlatilag egy szocialista gondolat,
hogy hogy segítsük az embereket, hogy
hogy legyen egy olyan létminimum, ami
tehát ez ez nem egy egy munkanélküli
segély. Ez ez valami, amiből meg lehet
élni, amiből házat lehet vásárolni, ami
amivel robotot lehet már vásárolni.
>> És és az ember lelke ilyen szempontból
nagyon ellentétes, ellentmondásos, mert
egyszerre akarunk fegyelmet és egyszerre
akarunk kényelmet, de a kettő kizárja
egymást. Ühüm.
>> Ez ezt te tudod a legjobban, hogy
kényelmes volt-e neked havonta elutazni
Bukarestbe? Kényelmes volt-e ennyi
mindent csinálni az életedben? Nem a
kényelmet kerested, hanem valami mást.
És ahhoz pedig fegyelem kell. kizárja a
fegyelem a a kényelmet. Ugyanígy van
például a kalanddal és a biztonsággal,
hogy egyszerre szeretne biztonságot,
egyszerre szeretne kalandot. Sajnos a
kettő nem keveredik, mert nem lehet
biztonságos kalandot
ez a definíciója a kalandnak, hogy van
benne valami bizonytalanság. És
kérdéses számomra, hogy tényleg
kényelmet akar az ember magának, tényleg
azt akarja, hogy hogy biztonságban
legyen, hogy semmit ne akarjon csinálni.
És a a amikor bejön a universal basic
income, ez a UBI, akkor akkor egész nap
ne csináljunk semmit, hanem van egy
ilyen utópisztikus gondolatunk, hogy
megyünk festőnk és verset írunk.
>> Igen, igen. Mindenki ezt szokta mondani,
hogy akkor és
>> és Nietzsche pont azt mondta, hogy
amikor eljön ez a pillanat és ezelőtt
már hány évvel élt Nietzse? 150 évvel,
most nem nem emlékszem már, hogy mikor
szett olyasmi. Már akkor látta, hogy ez
a kommunizmus
>> véres forradalomba fog ez majd és egy
terrorba fog majd végződni. Az embernek
nem erre azt mondta, hogy amikor már
mindene meglesz, akkor csak azért, hogy
ne unja magát valamit el fog rontani,
valamibe bele fog rúgni, valamit szét
fog törni.
>> Igen, azért ne unja magát. Így van.
>> Azért, hogy ne unja magát.
Bontok ez három része szerintem, mert ez
nehéz egyből egyből erre válaszolni.
Ugye azt fejembe szétbontottam. De
beszéljünk a társadalmi rétegződésről,
beszéljünk erről a kényelembiztonságról,
és akkor utána beszéljünk erről a a
Universal Basic Incomeról.
A az MIT-n a volt egy kutató, 2018-ban
publikált egy cikket, Morgan Frank a
neve. egyébként ugyanannál a ugyanannál
a vezető tanárnál volt, ahol én is. És
ők azt nézték meg, hogy melyek azok a
szakmák,
amelyek tehát ez még 18-ban volt, akkor
még ezek a Transformer modellek nem
igazán voltak nagyon nagyon elterjedtek,
de már akkor arra jutottak, hogy azok a
szakmák, amelyek ugye a kék galéros, a
blue color szakmák, ezek sokkal
egyszerűbben lesznek automatizálhatóak,
mint a fehér galérios szakmák. Azóta egy
picit megváltozott, talán most már
vannak, de de fehér általánosságban
végve azért még nagyon igaz, de vannak
olyan vannak olyan fehér galérios
szakmák, amelyek például a programozó,
ugye amiben talán mind a ketten egy
kicsit belelátunk,
>> ott is megtizedelődnek a
>> ami azért látjuk, hogy mekkora a
Microsoft ilyen 20000 ember bocsájtott
el a 100zres
állományából. Úgyhogy
>> sőt egy rövid zárójelet ide beszúrok. Én
pont azt látom, hogy a a vízgásszerelő
az, aki nagyobb biztonságban van ebben a
pillanatban. Igen, majdnem megfordulni
látszik, ugye, tehát a a a kezünket úgy
látjuk, hogy nehezebb lesz helyetteseni,
mint az agyunkat. Tehát na nagyon na
most akkoriban még a nyilván a a az
amerikai kékgarléos szakmák azért ez egy
amerikai tanulmány, az nyilván az ilyen
hosszútávú szállítás meg a a
futószalagos munkának a kiváltására
vonatkozott, ami ami lehet, hogy talán
nem is baj, hogyha hogyha hogyha
kiváltjuk.
Na de ott is ott az az volt annak a
kutatásnak az eredménye, hogy a a akik
akik jelenleg is talán kisebb
jövedelemmel rendelkeznek a
társadalomban, azok könnyebben
automatizálható munkák lesznek. Ez nem
föltétlenül jelenti azt, hogy korreláció
van a jövedelem és a és a és az IQ
között. Talán én ezt erről is sajnos
nincsen adatom.
Talán is hajlamosb len hajlamosak
lennénk azt mondani talán, hogy hogy
vagy te lehet, hogy tudod, akkor ez
tényleg van. Hát ez a a a PA koleráció,
ugye ez a valami 0,36, ami az egy ez egy
nagyon erős koráció korreláció.
>> Tehát hogyha neked hogyha a
Haranggörbének a a 100 alatti részén
vagy, akkor valószínűleg kisebb
jövedelemhez átlagosan ugye
>> de ez nem olyan meglepő, tehát
fájdalmas. Tehát zsigerből nyilván
hajlamosak lennék ezt a választ adni,
csak én én adatokra adatokat szeretek
azért 0,3 pont azt jelenti, amit
mondtál, hogy hogy be kell csillagozzuk,
hogy az nem azt jelenti, hogy 100% nem
minden okos ember gazdag és nem minden
szegény ember.
Abszolút. Igen. Tehát talán mondhatjuk
azt a trendet, hogy akkor a a
Haranggörbének az alja lesz hamarabb
kiváltva. Mondjuk lesznek olyanok, akik
nyilván a 140-es részen is ki lesznek
váltva. Pont ahogy mondtad. De ö ez ez
mindenképpen akkor ez egy olyan, hogyha
ezt tudományilag adatokkal alátámasztva
tudjuk igazolni, akkor ez mindenképpen
egy olyan eredmény, amire én, mint egy
kormány, akinek az az érdeke, hogy a a
társadalmam minden résztvevője,
hát legalább egyenlő eséllyel, vagy
valamilyen kiegyenlített eséllyel,
legalább egy mesterségesen kiegyenlített
eséllyel, hogyha nem is lesz végül
egyenlő,
induljon neki az életnek, akkor meg
tudnád indokolni, hogy a universal basic
inka talán nem is kellene universal
legyen, hanem majdnem egy ilyen ilyen
ilyen csökkenést kellene mutasson a ahol
nagyobb lesz a haranggörbétől
a a 100-astól távolabb esőérték. Akkor
én azt válasz erre én azt válaszolnám,
hogy
valójában a jelenlegi társadalmaink
nem gravitálnak már efelé a modell felé,
csak még az értékek talán picikék. Tehát
mondjuk az, aki
aki aki mondjuk állami juttatás
formájában hozzájut bevételhez, az az
általában nem az lesz, aki amúgy is
magas jövedelem rendelkezik. Sőt, a
magas jövedelmet ugye progresszíven
nagyobb adó. Romániát nehezen tudjuk
felhozni példának, mert itt egy picit
ugye ilyen ilyen mékas van, de a magas
jövedelmeket általában nagyobb
adóteherrel
sújtjuk, amit mondhatnál, amit
megfogalmazhatunk úgy, mint egy negatív
universal basic income. Most nyilván ez
benne van a tehát itt az univerzalitá az
univerzalitás talán esik. Itt a basic is
meg tudnánk támadni, mert ez csak akkor
lesz ugye, hogyha mondjuk valaki nem
dolgozik, akkor tud juttatáshoz jutni,
és hogyha valaki csak dolgozik, akkor
lehet őt megadóztatni és akkor a a UBI
azt tudja elvenni ezt, hogy te ha
dolgozol, ha nem, akkor lenne valamilyen
juttatásod.
Ugye nagyon tematizált ez a universal
basic income. Külön vannak országok,
tehát például a Svájcban tudom, hogy
próbálkoztak ennek a bevezetésével.
Különböző államokban talán Colorado
állam vagy uta állam talán egy egy ideig
próbálkozott ennek a bevezetésével.
És
az biztos, hogy hogyha hogyha fix a fix
összeges fix összegesről van szó, az
biztos, hogy a fix az összeg, akkor
tegyük fel azt, hogyha ez egy 1000 eurós
összeg, akkor nyilván annak, akinek a
jelenlegi bevétele mondjuk 1000€ alatt
van, vagy akár 500€ alatt van, az annak
egy óriási nagy segítség a abból a
szempontból, hogy most hirtelen
megduplázná a bevételét. És az óriási
stresszet, tehát könnyű könnyű könnyű
ítélkezni az emberek fölött, hogy ahogy
mondtad, akkor lehet, hogy azt tehát
mondjuk úgy, hogy elherdálnák valami.
Könnyű ezt a ezt a Voxarkot így hamar
hamar bekeríteni, de azért ez nem mindig
nem mindig így van szerintem. Tehát
lehet, hogy pontosan arra van szükség,
hogy azt a azt a stresszkorlátot levegye
a a válukról, hogy aztán tudjanak később
gondolkodni, mert kifejezetten a a görbe
nagyon nagy végén az emberek egy óriási
folyamatos és soha nem szűnös stresszben
élnek, ami ami pontosan által általában
pontosan a a valjában az a szegénységből
fakad. És hogy akkor ezt valamilyen
szinten amortizálni tudnánk, akkor
lehet, hogy
meg tudnának egy picit az emberek
nyugodni, és tudnának tényleg azzal
gondolkodni, hogy ha én amúgy dolgoznék,
akkor vajon mit tudnék csinálni? Tehát
sokszor nem jutnak ez ehhez a szintre el
az emberek. Ugyanakkor a Harangörbe
másik végén, hogyha valakinek mondjuk 50
vagy 100000 eurós bevétele van, akkor
neki az extra 1000, vagy a mondjuk,
hogyha az havonta lefordítódna 5000-re,
akkor az extra 1000
arányilag nem lenne akkora nagy
akkora nagy módosítás. És akkor az a
azonnali támadás erre az, hogy akkor
miért legyen universal? Mert akkor
ezeket a ezeket a pénzösszegeket miért
ne költen akkor miért ne adnán 2000et a
a Harangőrbe aljának, mert akkor lehet,
hogy az még többet segítene. Most és
ezért szerintem a jelenleg a univers
income a mint ötlet az nagyszerű és
nagyon sokan tárgyalják. A nehézség az,
hogy mi a szám. Nem tudjuk belőni a
számot, mert ha a szám 10000, akkor is
megtámadjuk, és hogyha a szám 100, akkor
is megtámadjuk.
>> Pontosan. Ez ez egy komplex kérdés, és
minden nehéz kérdés, komplex kérdés,
mert ha nem, akkor megoldottuk volna
már. Csak erre a UBI-ra szerintem egy
külön podcast epizódot el tudnánk
tölteni. Úgyhogy én kicsit visszatérnék
megint a a mesterséges intelligenciához.
És
>> de mielőtt visszatérsz, hadd kérdezzek
vissza erről a biztonság
nár tudom, hogy te vagy a host, de
kihagytam a középsőt.
>> Nyugod a tehát a kényelem versus
biztonságra vissza szeretnék kérdezni,
ugye
>> kényelem versus fegyelem és a a kaland
és a biztonság, ezt állítottam.
kaland és biztonság, kényelem versus
fegyelem. Amikor
amikor mi ráklik mikor megnyitunk egy
weboldalt és ráklikkelünk arra, hogy
accept all cookies, hogy elfogadjuk az
összesit, akkor
az a kényelmes megoldás, mert a csak
akarunk menni tovább a tartalomra. De
hogyha hogyha benne létezünk abban, hogy
miről is szól az a az a süti, hogyha
valaki elmeséli nek és ugye sokat
savazzuk az EU-t, de például a
mindenféle túlszabályozás miatt,
ugye például a
az ugyancsak sokat savazott GDPR
törvénykezésnek ez az egyik hozama, hogy
mindegyik weboldalon most van egy ilyen
acceptal cookies.
És talán nagyon sokáig, vagy 15 évig
úgy, amíg nem értette az általános
társadalom, hogy miről is szól ez, hogy
mindenki klikkelte azt, hogy accepttól
menjünk, haladjunk, de most ahogy egyre
inkább kezdjük érteni azt, hogy miről is
szól ez az adat, az adatbegyűjtés, ez
nem arról szól, hogy most én XY
csaladénes ezen a címen vagyok, és most
én pont pontosan ki vagyok. Az eleinte
talán ez volt a narratíva, de csak
azért, mert szerint nem volt egy ilyen
információtörés.
Ugye kezdjük megérteni, hogy ez a cookie
az nem azt csinálja, hanem azt azt azt
csinálja, hogyha ezen az oldalon én így
klikkeltem, és utána a láncolva a másik
oldalra eljutottam, és ott azt a abban a
témában kerestem valamit, akkor ezáltal
felépítenek egy virtuális képet a
személyünkről,
ami most már szerencsére kifejezetten a
mesterséges intelligencia alkalmazásak
miatt egyre inkább egyértelműen jelen
van a társadalomban, hogy jaj, begyűjtik
az adatainkat, jaj mit mit vigyázz, mit
kérdezel a chatgép GPT-től az örökre ott
marad.
Akkor most már szerintem azért egyre
jobban, egyre többen klikkelnek azt,
hogy no reject all, de csak ugye az
oldalaknál nem mindig van no reject all,
úgyhogy néha be kell menni a harmadik
menübe, és mindegyiket ki kell
pipálgatni. Az neked egy extra 10 perc.
É o furcs, furcsa példa, de tehát meg
tudnád indokolni azt, hogy feladnánk a
kényelmet a a biztonságunkért, de ez
csak azért van, mert kezdtük megérteni,
hogy mit is jelent ez a mi az ára a
kényelemnek. Régát, hogyha úgy kezdünk
gondolni egy ilyen kukira, mint a mint
egy besugóra a kommunizmusba,
>> akkor akkor abban a pillanatban már
egyből akkor már egy egyből egyből
feladjuk a kényelmünket.
>> De miért nem használjuk akkor a magyar
interneten? Miért nem használjuk ezt a
nyelvezetet?
>> Elfogadod a besugókat? Most jött fel ez
a gondol. Ez
>> nagyszerű.
>> Igen. Jó, kanyarodjunk vissza az AI-hoz,
és majd még még kalandozhattunk ebbe az
irányba, mert gyakorlatilag én én én
pont azt akartam megkérdezni, hogy
az emberiségnek oka van az aggodalomra.
Én azt látom, hogy tényleg a vadnyugati
hangulat, a kaland, tehát emiatt
vadnyugat, rengeteg visszaéléssel,
veszéllyel fenyegetés, rengeteg rengeteg
minden változik, és az emberek nem
szeretnek változni. Nem szeretnek
tanulni sem. A tanulás is amúgy egy
változás. Nagyon nehezen tanulnak,
nagyon tanulunk. Ez egy fájdalmas, hogy
éberekkel legyünk, amik közben tanulunk.
Tehát nem a szórakozásban
nem tanulunk annyira, hogyha
szórakozunk. Ez például az egyik
felismerésem a Duolingoval volt, hogy én
én azt hittem, hogy a Duolingoval
nagyon-nagyon gyorsan fognak tanulni a
gyermekeim
>> angolt például, mert játszva tanulnak.
Ez volt az én hipotézisem, hogy játék
közben tart igen, gamification. És
nyilván van a gamificationnek egy
pozitív hatása, hogy hogy ott tartja a
telefon előtt. Viszont arra kezdtem
rájönni, hogy már a tanul, amennyi
energiát és időt töltenek a a
duolingóval, annyit nem tanulnak vele
arányosan, hanem hanem beszippantja egy
dopamin forrásként úgy, úgy beszippantja
őket ez a duolingo. És azt látom, hogy
ezt nem lehet kikerülni. Tehát, hogy
amikor valaki tanul valamit, akkor
összezúzódik a világképe és újra kell
építse. Nincs más út. Ha nem zúzódik
össze, akkor valószínűleg nem tanult
semmi újat, hanem inkább csak
szórakozott. És most egy olyan világot
élünk, ahol minden változik. Tehát ahogy
mondtad, ezelőtt
40 évvel körülbelül, amikor a robotkarok
vagy 30 évvel kezdtek elterjedni, akkor
a a kék galéros munkásoknak a a munkáit
kezdték lecserélni, és ők akulthattak,
és kacagtunk. Mi nem kacagtunk, hanem
hogy nyugodtan hátradőlhetett a fehér
gallos munkás, hogy na ez velünk soha
nem fog megtörténni, ami most éppen
megtörténik. Tehát látom én, hogy hány
munkatársamat küldi el egy stratégiai
partnerünk amiatt, mert mert nem
egyszerűen az van, hogyha nem tud
változni, nem tud nem tud felzárkózni,
nem tudja használni, hogy hogy gyorsabb
és produktívabb legyen, akkor akkor már
nem fogja tudni egy idő után kifizetni a
fizetését. Nem azért, mert gonosz
kapitalista, hanem egyszerűen azért,
mert kevesebb idő alatt ugyanazt az
órabért akkor adják meg, hogy a többet
szolgáltatunk. És tehát, hogy hogy
visszatérve ehhez, hogy azt látom, hogy
van van is ami miatt aggódnia. Ez egy ez
egy stressz, ami most történik a
világban. És ezzel párhuzamosan most
például az egyik statisztika, nem tudom,
hogy tudtad-e, hogy a a világon a
leggyakoribb szakma micsoda? A elmondom,
mert lehet, hogy pont
>> kaszás talán
>> ne a sofőr
>> a sofőr
>> tehát a a kamionsofőrökre értem sof,
tehát aki autót vezet, és most nyilván
látjuk azt, hogy ez most már nem
technológiai kérdés, inkább ilyen
politikai kérdés, hogy beengedjük-e az
önvezető járműveket, vagy nem.
Ez ez egy évtizeden belül gyakorlatilag
azonnal le fog cserélődni, mert
gyakorlatilag az a cég, amelyik nem
hajlandó lecserélni, az a az csődbe fog
menni. Igen. Tehát ilyen ilyen last mile
sofőrök lesznek, amikor be kell
manőverezni a a
paletták közé, akkor oda kell egy ember,
de az autópályán azért
>> hát talán talán, de az autópályán, tehát
hogy ott azok a kamionsofőrök, akiket
most így ismerünk és több millióan nap
mint nap, éjjel nappal hordják az
árukat, egy olyan évtized múlva ezek
minderséges intelligenciával vezetett
autók lesznek. Na most ez egy óriási
kifejezetten székelyföld szempontból ö
ez egy óriási alkodalomra való ok nekünk
ugye mert itt azért a gazdaságnak egy
ilyen 1yede káb származik szállításból
hogyha a székelyföet nézzük
>> ez egy stresszforrás de ott van a
humanoid robotoknak a a hihetetlen
fejlődése, mert gyakorlatilag eddig is
fejlődtek, de amikor a mesterséges
intelligencia ilyen szinten elkezdett
berobbanni az életünkben, egy új
lendületet kapott ez is. És szerintem
időkérdése az, amikor a talicskát egy
építkezésen már egy humanoid robot fogja
tolni. Ühüm.
>> Ez egyféle
veszélyforrás fenyeget minket, és persze
ahol veszély van, ott lehetőség van,
viszont viszont attól még van veszély.
Szóval egy kicsit erről akartam
beszélgetni erről az a erről a
témakörről, hogy te hogyan közelíted meg
ezt a fajta vadnyugati hangulatot? Mit
mondanál így diáknak, aki most kezdi el
az egyetemet? Nem az, hogy mit tanuljon,
hanem hogy mi fog jönni, mire számítson.
>> Ez ez nagyon furcsa, mert ugye talán a
Prisóban még beszélgettük, hogy próbálom
digoglifyolni az életemet. Tehát annak
ellenére, hogy én ezt oktatom,
mesterséges intelligenciát vagy
géptanulást oktatok.
A a személyes interakciómban próbálok
minél kevesebb adatot megosztani a
különböző algoritmusokon. Most itt
fontos azt, de ezt a ezt az alfa
generáció nálunk sokkal jobban tudja.
Tehát ők ők sokkal szkeptikusabbak
nálunk. Ők mindent háromszor
megkérdjeleznek. Úgyhogy ez egy
valában ez egy pozitív dolog, és ilyen
reményre reményre ad okot, de de
próbálom az adataimat
minél jobban olyan szolgáltatások felé,
és most már nagyon sok alternatíva van,
ugye a nagy, mit tudom én, Microsoft meg
Google meg Apple
ön kívül, ahol a különböző
szolgáltatásokat el el tudjuk érni.
Tehát én én nagyon próbálom az adataimat
őrizni ebből a ebből a szempontból.
Talán itt ezt úgy válaszolnám ezt a
kérdést meg, hogyha kezdjük érteni, hogy
és ez nagyon veszélyes egyébként, hogy
milyen adatokat osztunk meg a nagy
nyelvű modellekkel, de talán legalább
annyira veszélyes az, hogy amit a nyelvi
modell ad válasznak, azt azt elhisszük,
mint egyetemes igazság. És akkor talán,
hogyha megértjük, hogy hogy működik a
nagy nyelvi modell, az az segíteni fog.
Ugye neki általában két nagy stádium
van. Van a, amit úgy neveznek, hogy
prerraining,
ami az azt jelenti, hogy elm elmegy a
nagy nyelvi modell, kiolvassa az
internetet, és most már tényleg ennél a
régebb ez csak a a a Székelyviccben
volt, de most már tényleg ennél a a
stádiumnál tartunk, hogy egy GPT 5-ös,
ami a múlt héten jött ki, az minden
egyes információ, ami fellelhető az
interneten, azt valójában elolvasta. A
3.5-ös GPT az első, amelyiken chatpap
volt, az nagyrészt a Wikipédián tanult.
Most már azért mindent mindent
elolvastak. A különbség a Google modell
és a Facebook modell között onnan jön,
hogy a Google-nek ugye van kis millió
kereséshez,
meg talán és talán nem biztos, de lehet
emailekhez.
Illetve a Facebooknál ugye ott egy igazi
közösség van, ezért ezért jobb a
különböző feladatokban. A Facebook
modell, hogyha konverzációt kell
éteseni, már sok ilyent látott, ezért
ezért jobban tudre erre válaszolni. Na
de ez a ez a pretraining, amikor így a
meglevő interneten megtanulják, hogy
amikor ilyen szöveget láttam, akkor
általában ez szokott következni utána.
És a a nagy nyelvi modell az valójában
csak egy ilyen idősoros előrejelzés.
Ugye amikor az idősorban látod, hogy a a
négyes után jön egy ötös, építettél
valamilyen modellt, hogy azt
előrejelezze. Ugyanez, csak itt most nem
betűk vannak, hanem szavak. kicsit
összetettebb, mert hogyha neked van egy
oldalad, akkor az az emberi szem
automatikusan vannak né van néhány ilyen
szó, ami úgy kiugrik az oldalról, ugye
elmondja, hogy ha van például egy
karakternek a neve azon, vagy egy nagy
betű van, akkor igazából az ad
jelentést, és nem az és vagy szavak. És
ezt csinálja kábé a a nagynyelvi modell
is. Na de van a második rész,
amiről talán kevesebben tudnak, ez az
RLHF, reinforcement learning and human
feedback. Ez azt ez azt jelenti, hogy
miután megvolt a pretraining, akkor
mondjuk egy modell többféle nyilván van
itt sok sztokasztikus változó, tehát
véletlenszerű változót. Hogyha kétszer
ugyanazt megkérdezzük, nem pont ugyanazt
fogja válaszolni. Akkor egy embert
odaállíthatunk, és akkor megm
megkérdezhetjük, hogy most szerinted ez
human like emberiibb válasz, vagy ez
emberib válasz? És ez volt az igazi nagy
lépés a GPT3-as és a 3.5-ös, amiből lett
a chat GPT között a különbség, hogy a
3.5-ösnek volt reinforcement learning
human feedbackje.
Na most
ez a folyamat nyilván arra is
felhasználható, hogy emberi válaszokat
adjon, de arra is felhasználható, hogyha
az AI tulajdonosai, az overlordok, ahogy
szokták hívni a a az iparon belül, azt
mondják, hogy ha hátha például erről
kérdeznek, akkor akkor erről te ne
válaszoljál. Például ugye a a
kínai modelleket, a deep seeket meg a
meg a quent, azokat nagyon nehéz rávenni
arra. Minden stokasztikus, úgyhogy kellő
erőfeszítéssel csak lehet, de nagyon
nehéz rávenni arra, hogy negatívumot
mondjon például a kínai kommunista
pártól. Ugyanígy például az összes
amerikai modellt nagyon nehéz rávenni
arra, hogy negatívumot mondjon például
Izraelről.
Úgyhogy na én egyre inkább szkeptikus
vagyok, és mindent ötször megkérdezek
különböző és majdnem úgy, majdnem úgy
meg kell mondani, hogy mi lenne
egyébként, mi lenne az ellenpélda, vagy
mi lenne az ellenszemszög, és hogyha
elmondod a nagynyelvi modellnek, hogy
igen, de erre nem figyeltél, akkor úgy
megpróbál átmenni ezen a vagy elég
nehéz, mert bizonyos ilyen különböző
védelmi szintek vannak úgymond benne.
Tehát például, hogyha megkérdezed egy
nagy nyelvi modellt arról, hogy az
Európai Unió az egy jó dolog-e, vagy egy
rossz dolog, neki az alapválasza a semmi
kontextus nélkül az, hogy ez egy jó
dolog. De hogyha megpróbálod felvezetni,
hogy igen, de például a bizonyos
államoknak vagy a kelet-európai
államoknak
óriási demográfiai változásokat hozott
be, hogyha ezt egyszer elbeszélgeted, és
akkor ez bekerül a kontextusba, akkor
már nem automatikusan azzal fog
válaszolni, hogy ez egy jó dolog vagy
egy rossz dolog. Ebből a szempontból
szerintem nagyon nagyon emberi, mert az
emberek is így így így működnek. Na de
nagyon szkeptikusnak kell szerintem
lenni a a nagynyelvi modell által adott
válaszra.
Azért, mert amikor a Google ad neked egy
keresési választ, azt valamilyen szinten
le tudod le tudod tesztelni, vissza
tudod vezetni, hogy miért adta neked azt
a választ. Az egy ad egy adott linket
azért linkel be, mert nagyon sok oldal
iik hozzá. Nyilván ennél sokkal
összetettebb, de ez az alapötlet. Egy
nagy nyelvű modell az egy fekete doboz.
nem tudod, hogy neked miért fog választ
adni. Ez egyért oktatási szempontból
nagyon-nagyon veszélyes az, hogy azt
mondjuk, hogy tehát dualingot hoztad fel
példának, de vannak ugye YouTube-on sok
olyan példa, aki
át akar menni egy bizonyos vizsgán, és
akkor a chatgépét megtanítja. Most a
példák azok általában ilyen reasoning
alap, ugye ilyen mondjuk úgy itt
reálosabb beállítottság a vizsgák, ahol
talán kevésbé számít az, hogy a
modellnek milyen etikai beállítottsága
van, de hogyha ezt olyan területekre
visszük át, ahol ez nem egyértelmű,
hogyha kérdezünk egy történelmi kérdést,
ahol van két fél, és mindegyik hősnek
látja saját saját magát és terroristának
a másik felett, akkor én nagyon-nagyon
nehezen hinném el azt a választ, amit a
a amit a modell mond, és nagyon sok
esetben ezt nem is tudjuk. Tehát van egy
csomó rejtett
ilyen mederbe terelgetés, amit nem
tudunk. Úgyhogy
ami ami és ez nem ez egy rossz indulat,
hanem így működnek ezek a modellek. Így
lehet őket betanítani. Túl összetettek
ahhoz, hogy ellenőrizni tudjuk, hogy
hogy adnak, hogy hogy adnak választ.
Amikor akkor engem inkább abba az
irányba terelne, hogy akkor ne
használjam egyáltalán.
És a az igazi nehéz kérdés, talán te is,
te is nem tudom, hogyha erre gondoltál,
nincsen olyan a most már az internetben
nincsen olyan, hogy egy kicsit veszünk
részt. Tehát vagy részt veszünk, vagy
visszamegyünk a Nokia 3310-eshez. De
hogyha részt veszünk, még akkor is,
hogyha próbálod diguglifyolni magad,
nincsen az a lehetőség, hogy ne osszál
meg magadról adatot. És sokszor
a a saját sok sok anélkül, hogy el errel
kifejezetten beleegyeznél, meg
megosztasz megosztasz adatokat. Tehát
itt van egy elég nagy ilyen
hit, amit belevetünk a nagy nyelvű
modellt összerakó cégbe, akik különböző
országokban, különböző törvénykezések
alatt futnak. Úgyhogy ez egy nagyon
nehéz, nagyon nehéz szituációt hoz hoz
létre. A válaszom az az lenne, hogy meg
kell kérdezni ötször, akár csak egy
embertől. Meg kell kérdezni ötször, hogy
tényleg tényleg ezt gondolod, de nem
gondoltál erre is. Úgy el kell
beszélgetni. Nem elég egy választ
elhinni a nagy nyelvben, de úgy el kell
beszélgetni mer és az oktatásban is
akkor ez végül is
odavezetne, ami így szépen majdnem
keretbe zárja. hogyha többször
megkérdezel valamit, akkor akkor nem a
megoldás, hanem inkább a megértés
irányába próbálod terelni ezt a
beszélgetést, mert neked a neked a én én
úgy gondolom, hogy az oktatásnak az
lenne a része, a nagynyelvű modell az
minden témában egy ilyen PhD szintű
oktató, akkor beszélgessél sokat vele,
hogy minél többet ki tudjál húzni belőle
azáltal, hogy fel tud építeni a
megértést a a saját
gondolatrendszeredbe. Ez nagyon tetszik
ez az irány, amibe elindultunk, mert
valójában erről akarok veled
beszélgetni, hogy kié lesz a jövő, kik
milyen milyen kvalitásai kell legyenek a
jövő embereinek ahhoz, hogy sikeresen
tudjanak
boldogulni az életben. Egyik oldalról
azt mondtad, hogy nincs visszaút, és én
is így látom, hogy valójában ha vissza
akarunk menni, elvonulni ettől a
társadalomtól elvonulni, amit még lehet,
de ez egy luxus. kicsit olyan, mint az
ámisok Amerikában, hogy hogy meg lehet
tenni egy ilyen kuriózum, egy mintogyha
ilyen rezervátumba élnének, de az igazi
problémákhoz, mint a hobbitok a a
Gyűrűkurában, hogy hogy védeni kell
őket, kicsik kedvesek, de valójában
nincs erejük, nem tudnak változtatni,
azt csinálják, ami a múlt múltban már
volt, azt megismétlik újra is egy
biztonságos, önként vállalt vakságban
élnek. Ha nem akarunk így élni, akkor
viszont előre kell menjünk. És pont
erről akartam beszélgetni, hogy most
elképzelek valakit, aki itt ül, egy
fiatal
alfa generációs valaki, aki nyitott
szemekkel figyeli a mi Y generációs
véleményünket, hogy hogy mit tanácsolunk
nekik, hogy mi legyen, hogyan tanuljon,
hogyan használja az AI-t, és mi ki mi
lesz az, amit az AI nem fog tudni
lecserélni bennünk, mert valójában azt
látom egy olyan tendenciát, hogy minden,
ami gépi bennünk, azt le fogja tudni
cserélni az AI, úgy ahogy már gyököt
senki. Nem van papíron,
>> ami ismétlődő, azokat a feladatokat
nagyon jól megoldja, de kreativitásban
még annyira nem jó. Tehát új dolgokat
nehezen tud összerakni. És akkor akkor
beszélgessük egy picit erről, hogy tehát
mi például az egyik, amit mondtál, az az
egy nagyon fontos dolog, hogy én kábé
úgy gondolok a a gondolkodási
folyamatra, mint egy navigációs
kérdésre,
>> hogy navigálunk az ideák világában, és a
ha a chat GPT-t arra használjuk, hogy
hogy segítsen minket, tehát mi mi
vagyunk azok, akik navigálunk, és a chat
GPT az, amelyik adja a folyamatos
véleményeket, erre is mehetnénk, arra is
mehetnénk, és mi vagyunk azok, akik
döntünk. Ha a chat GPT dönt helyettünk,
kicsit olyan, mint amikor van egy 1000
lóerős autónk, de nem behonjuk a
szemünket és csak úgy össze-vissza
vezetnénk vele. Valószínűleg az első, ha
szerencsénk van, első kanyart megússzuk,
a másodikat már viszont nem.
>> Ez történik akkor, hogyha valaki ész
nélkül használja a chat GPT-t, tehát
hogy megír vele egy olyan
nem tudom essét, ami vagy vagy egy olyan
tudományos dolgozatot, ami jól hangzik,
de egy szakavatot számára gyakorlatilag
az első öt percben kiderül, hogy ez ez
bullshit. Úgyhogy, úgyhogy gyakorlatilag
meg kell tanuljunk navigálni az
információk között. És erről beszéltél,
hogy például az egyik praktikus, itt van
az alfa generációs nevezzük Péternek.
Péter, tanulj meg navigálni, tanulj meg
kritikusan gondolkozni, tanulj meg több
modellt egymás ellen kijátszani. Tanulj
meg, tanulj meg megpróbálni azokat a
kérdéseket, amelyekre nincs igen vagy
nemes válasz, a lehető legkönnyebben
megfogalmazni, mert tegyük fel most egy
matematikai kérdésnél, hogyan kell
megoldani egy egyenletet, egy reasoning
modell, elég jó választ ad, és a vége,
hogyha kijön, akkor akkor akkor az
helyes. Viszont mi a helyzet a a
pszichológiai kérdésekkel? mi a helyzet,
ahogy mondtad, a politikai meg egyéb
emberi kérdésekkel, ott viszont
mélyíteni kell az általános
műveltségünket, és ezt úgy tudjuk, hogy
nem egy nem egy forrást nézünk, hanem
több forrást összehasonlítva. Ez e ez ez
nagyon tetszik. Tehát, hogy
gyakorlatilag akkor Péter tanulj meg
navigálni és használd a a chat GPT nem a
navigációs rendszered, hanem te vagy a
navigációs rendszer, és a chat GPT
gyakorlatilag adja számodra a különböző
térképelemeket, és eldöntöd, hogy az
helyes-e vagy nem helyes.
>> Így van. Így amikor kiválasztod a
GPS-ből, hogy az egyes útvonal vagy a
kettes útvonal, és akkor
>> meg hogyha letérsz az útron, akkor utána
tud neked új útvonalat tervezni. Ez ez
ez nekem tetszik ez az analógia.
Az talán még talán még azt tenném hozzá,
hogy a a
nagyon sok esetben
az alfa generáció
pontosan azért, mert
tehát mi még mi még úgy nőttünk fel,
hogy az internet akkor jött be a
felnövési folyamatunk során.
Az alfa generáció az már béb korától
ugye az internettel az internettel nőtt
fel, úgyhogy ezért szerintem kialakult
bennük egy sokkal erősebb
védekezési mechanizmus, mondhatjuk
szkepticizmusnak,
mint bennünk. Úgyhogy szerintem kevésbé
kell félteni őket, mint mint gondoljuk.
Ez az első. A a második gondolatom az
pedig az, hogy talán a 20. század. Na
most már ugye jócskán benne vagy megyünk
a 21-ben, de a 20. század talán
a technológiai fejlődésről hozott, és
alapvetően a az emberi életnek tehát
kifejezetten itt mondjuk úgy én nem
igazán szeretem felosztani a világot
ilyen nyugati meg keleti vagy nem nem
tudom, de mondjuk így a a nyugat-európai
és a és az észak-amerikai életnek meg
talán később a kelet-európai és az
ázsiai életnek is a kényelmesebbé
tételéről szólt különböző technológiai
eszközök által. Mit tudom én most, de
van porszívónk, meg van kenyérpirítónk
és így tovább. A 21. századnak az eleje
ugye
ez áttért a kódírással. A technológia
csak egy bizonyos nagyon szűk
szektorban, csak az informatikai
szektorban való, főleg hát általában
mondják ezt kommunikációnak, de
általában az internet, ahogy átveszi
ennek a minden eszköznek koordinálását
és vezérlését, és az életünknek a
megszervezésében segít. Most szerintem a
a hátra levő része a 20. századnak az
egy nem technológiai rész lesz, hanem
itt inkább a a amit mi humánabb
tudományaknak nevezünk, ahogy ahogy
pontosan mondtad, a szociológia vagy az
antropológia
etikának a ami ami talán közelebb áll az
emberi mi voltunknak a meghatározásához,
ezeknek a tudományágaknak lesz az
újraértelmezése, mert eljutottunk odáig
technikailag,
hogy
fel kell tegyünk olyan kérdéseket, amit
talán Azelőtt magától értetődően a
kulturális közösség, a vallási közösség
automatikusan megválaszolt, és nem is
igazán hagyta a kérdésfelvetésnek a
jogát meg. Most már vannak olyan
eszközeink, vagy annyira úgymond nyitott
a világunk, hogy meg tudunk nézni is
különböző gondolkodásmódokat, meg tudjuk
engedni magunknak, hogy
megkérdőjelezzük, hogy ez vajon jó-e. És
akkor odajön, odajutunk, hogy akkor újra
kell definiáljuk azt, hogy mi a jó, vagy
mi a mi mi az elfogadott. És igen, ebben
viszont a a nagynyelvi modellek utat
tudnak nekünk mutatni, és talán így
saját magunkra jobban ki tudunk
teljesedni. De újra megcsillagozom azt,
hogy az az út, amit a nagynyelvű
modellek mutatnak, azt továbbra is óriás
skepticizmussal kell kezeljük, és
szerintem mi sokkal kevésbé tesszük ezt
meg, mint az alfa generáció. Úgyhogy
Péter, nem kell őt félteni.
>> Igen. Tehát, hogy megismétlem azt, amit
mondtál, mert nagyon tetszett, amit
mondtál, csak nem vagyok benne biztos,
hogy jól értettem. Azt értettem, hogy a
humán tantárgyak fel fognak értékelődni,
és a reál tantárgyak bizonyos
szempontból azok is hasznosak lesznek,
de bizonyos szempontból túl vol túl
voltak értékelve.
Túl nagy hangsúlyt fektettünk. Tehát
például látszik is itt Erdélyben az
elmúlt 10 évben, milyen presztízse volt
az informatikának, mennyit kerestek az
informatikusok, és bizonyos szempontból
csak regularizálódik ilyen szempontból a
a világunk. Tehát a filozófia, a
pszichológia, a diplomácia, a
konfliktusmenedzsment, a logika, ezek
ezek a kritikus gondolkodás, ezek ezek
fel fognak értékelődni, és talán egy így
cégnél fontosabb lesz az, hogy valaki
konfliktust tudjon megoldani, hogy hogy
egy jó diplomata legyen. Például szín és
stílus tanácsadás, hogy hogyan
öltözködik valaki, hogyan jelenik meg,
hogyan beszél, milyen beszédtechnika
például ezek mind olyan dolgok, amik
ember teljesen emberiek. Nincs is
értelme beszédtechnikáról beszélni a
chat GPT esetében, de de az emberek
esetében van. És és akkor felmerül a
kérdés, Péter, hogy miért fontosak
ezeket tanulni? Miért fontosak ezeket
tanulni? Nem fog mindent lecserélni
ilyen szempontból a az AI minden egyes
interakciót. És a és és miért nem miért
nem miért nem tudjuk kikerülni az
embereket?
Szerintem van egy mínusz egyedik kérdés.
A miért fontos ezelőtt az, hogy
fontos-e. És én én nem vagyok
egyértelműen biztos abban, hogy fontos.
Tehát én nem biztos, hogy most ez ilyen
istenkáromlás szintűnek fog hangzani.
Nem biztos, hogy kell tanítani
matematikát az iskolába, hogyha meg
hogyha ugye én nyilván én szeretem
tiszta, hogy melyik táborban vagyok, de
a fontos-e mire értetted ezt, hogy
egyáltalán feltenni a kérdés, hogy
fontos-e mi? Tehát, hogy fontos-e
egyáltalán a reálantárgyakat továbbra is
azzal a az azzal a a vehemencivel szigor
>> vehemcal kezelni, vagy szigorral
kezelni, mint mint ahogy
>> Igen. Jó, értem, értem. Oké.
>> Mert
ugye nyilván hamar behelyeznek
behelyezének engem az emberek abba a
táborba, aki ugye a matematika az isten
kábé. De hogyha hogyha meghúzzuk a
vonalat és megnézzük, hogy például
mekkora stresszet okoz a matematikai
oktatás az iskolában, nem biztos, hogy
egy
egy null szaldó kijön, nem biztos, hogy
egy egy pozitív mérleg jön ki, akkor
lehet, hogy inkább azt kellene a
matematika helyett inkább azt kellene
megtanuljuk, ilyen ilyen prompt
engineeringet tanuljunk, hogy hogyan
tudjuk a jelenlegi nyelvi modelleinket
felhasználni arra, hogy a matematikai
elveket tanuljuk meg. nem a matematikát,
mint magát, hanem magának a a számok
összeadásának, kivonásának a a világát.
Egy kicsit ez ilyen furcsa, de ugyanígy
lehet, hogy helyettesít nem nem
föltétlenül a matematikát kellene
helyettesíteni ezzel, hanem például kell
tanuljunk kódolást, kell tanuljunk
Pythont-t, vagy C++, vagy mit tanulnunk
az iskolába. Lehet, hogy ahelyett inkább
azt kellene megtanuljuk, hogy hogyan
működik egy nagy nyelvi modell.
Tanuljunk akkor supervised learninget,
felügyelt tanulást, vagy unsupervised
learninget, felügyeletlen tanulást, még
talán reinforcement learninget, ugye
megerősítéses tanulást is, mert azáltal,
hogyha megértjük azt, hogy az algoritmus
hogy működik, nyilván azt mondtam, hogy
egy fekete doboz nem tudjuk megérteni,
hogy lépésről lépésre hogy működik, de
hogy legalább mik a részei, akkor talán
edukáltabbak leszünk abban, hogy hogyan
menedzseljük az algoritmusokkal való
interakcióinkat. És ahogy mondtad, azért
elkerülhetetlen lesz az, hogy az
algoritmusokkal együtt éljünk. Úgyhogy a
fontosabb az az lesz, hogy hogyan tudunk
hatékonyan együttműködni ezzel az
algoritmussal. Hogyha és hogyha
felértékelődik, nyilván fel fog
értékelődni a a a humán terület, az nem
jelenti azt, hogy ha én szépen valamit
illusztrálni, hogyha én nekem van
például egy filozófiai elvem, ami ugye
most legyünk a legelvontabbak, azt
szépen illusztrálni szeretném. Lehet,
hogy ahhoz, hogy én azt illusztráljam,
és azt be kell mutassam majd 50
embernek, ahhoz kell építsek
mondjuk egy ilyen adatalapú
történetmeséléssel
egybekötött prezentációt, vagy egy
weboldalt, amit meg kell írassak majd a
chatg-vel, ami ahhoz, hogy olyan legyen,
amit én szeretnék, szépen el kell
mondjam, hogy ezen a területen mi a
fontos az én szempontomból, mire
szeretnék rávilágítani. Tehát bele kell
elkerülhetetlen lesz az, hogy a saját
emberi mivoltunkat belevigyük az
algoritmusba, és az alapján
válaszoltassuk őt. A
>> a saját emberi mi voltunk az a miért,
mert a chat GPT a mi érteken nem
gondolkozik. A chat GPT a hogyanonan
gondolkozik és a a min gondolkozik. Az
emberi ember például itt van a pólód egy
nagyon jó példa. A kedves nézőknek és
hallgatóknak leírom, hogyha nem fog
látszani, hogy az aranymetszésről van
egy egy nagyon szép ábra.
Azt, hogy hogyan kell kiszámolni az
aranymetszést, azt nem tudom, hogy hány
ember kell tudja, de a miértét, hogy
miért fontos az aranymetszés, és hogy
hogyan használjuk fel, miért miért miért
jelenik meg a természetben ennyiszer. Ez
ez a lényeg, hogyha ezt megtanulja az
emberiség a tanulóknak a 90%-a, akkor
győztünk. Hogyha és egy szűk kisebbség
megtanulja azt is, hogy hogyan lehet ezt
kiszámolni, akkor akkor az lehet, hogy
pont elég.
Nem, nem folytattad ugye, mert itt van
egy hullám is, és akkor ez bezárná a
hasonlatodat, hogy az aranymecszés ugye
a természetben nagyon sok helyen jelen
van. És akkor nekünk az az érdekes, hogy
például a hullámnak vagy a levélnek
miért van pont olyan formája, és akkor
neked a a nagy nyelvi modell el tudná
magyarázni, hogy így volt a fejlődés
során így a sok sok kicsinek a
kisváltozásnak az egy másétele így így
hozzá ki nagyobb formát. Jó,
>> Péter,
nagyon fontos beszéljünk arról, hogy
miért fontos az ember. Szerintem ez ez
egy nagyon fontos kérdés, hogy Pétert
megnyugtassuk, hogy ő még fontos.
>> Itt itt én egy én egy ilyen
>> tegyem fel a kérdést például,
>> de de de muszáj muszáj azért megmondjam,
hogy ilyen ilyen te tekes podcastba
jöttem és így egyre távolabbi vizekre
evezünk, úgyhogy egyre egyre kevésbé
érzem biztonságban magam, de de folytasd
a kérdés.
>> Nem baj, nem baj. birkózok a kérdésem,
mert ezekkel én is pont így birkózok, és
nem tudom a választ, és pont olyan
embereket keresek, akikkel lehet ezekkel
birkózni, mert két hét múlva meghívott a
városi könyvtár, hogy beszéljek arról a
mesterséges intelligenciáról, és és az
egyik kérdés, amit fel fogok tenni, és a
köré fogom majd építeni ezt az előadást,
az az, hogy mi szükség van a könyvtárra,
mi szükség van arra, hogy létezzen egy
könyvtár, egy könyvraktár, ha így
gondolunk a a könyvtárra, amit egy
könyvr raktár, akkor egy
akkor akkor elveszítette azt a azt a ami
körbevette eddig a könyvtárat. De
valójában a könyvtár az nem csak egy
könyvraktár,
az is, mert nyilván, hogyha kihúzzák a
az áramot a falból, és semmi nem marad,
ami digitális, ami időnként amúgy
megtörténhet, egy-egy napki törésnél
tegyük fel az emberiség fele, áram
nélkül marad egy jó ideig, ez
megtörténhet, akkor hol van elraktározva
az emberiségnek az információja? Hát
nyilván könyvekben van. Ez az egyik
legstabilabb forma, és rengeteg
szétosztott
példányszámban, hogy nem nagyon lehet
most már egy könyv, tehát nem lehet
elpusztítani egy információt ilyen
szempontból, de én úgy gondolom, ez csak
egy primitív leegyszerűsítése annak, ami
a könyvtárat körbeveszi, hogy milyen
szükség van még a könyvtárra.
>> És én azt hiszem, hogy a ami az elmúlt
10 évben történt, az egy nagy vadlov
lovaglás volt. Ide-oda dobott minket a
történelem, a háborúk, covid, ez a
mesterség és intelligencia. most a
humanoid robotok és és kapkodja az ember
a levegőt és itt van Péter az alfa
generációból, aki amúgy kapkodja a
levegőt. Tehát nem csak nyugodt, mert
úgy úgy állítottuk be, mintogyha
nyugodtak lennének. Sokkal neurotikusabb
ez a generáció. jobban fél, a
biztonságát jobban félti a és és látszik
is, hogy nem a a szaporulatai indexe
például a világnak, a Európának pláne,
de Dél-Koreának például szörnyű, tehát a
legfejlettebb országok között van
Dél-Korea. Szörnyű, tehát egy alatt van
az,
>> egy alatt van, igen. Nulla valamenny
>> 0,8 és Szulban pedig 0,56. Tehát
egyszerűen eszméletlen, hogy ami
történik velük, az egy ez egy
katasztrófa. És ezen gondolkozom, hogy
Péter vagy akár a gyermekeimnek, hogy
mit tudok mondani neki
megnyugtatásképpen,
hogy akarjon két gyermeket vállalni,
vagy 2,1 gyermeket vállalni.
>> Azt, hogy a mikor a most ezért ennél
klisésebbet nem lehet kitalálni
szerintem, de de azt kell mondjuk neki
szerintem, hogy és rá kell vezessük
arra, hogy maga a az élet az szép. Tehát
a az emberi létnek a lényege alapvetően
a szépségnek a felfedezése.
De ahogy mondtad, a legelső kérdésedben,
talán visszakanyarodunk a podcastnak az
elejére, ami talán érdekes zárógondolat
is lehet, hogy
a szép az nem föltétlenül jelenti a
könnyűt.
A szép az általában
izzadsághoz is kötött. És én én a
személyes tapasztalatom alapján én
nagyon szeretem azt, amikor egy mikor
egy egy oszlopdiagram pont ugyanolyan
színekkel, pont olyan elhelyezkedéssel
jelenik meg a képernyő, ahogy én azt
elképzeltemát magának, vagy ahogy te
megírsz egy kódot, és az a szoftver, az
működik.
A digitális terméknek is van egy ilyen
kiteljesedést adó élménye, de ez soha
nem lesz összehasonlítható azzal, mint
azzal az asztalossal, aki ezt az asztalt
elkészítette és rácsavarozta a tetejét,
mert alapvetően ugye számos film van,
például Ready Player One, vagy a Black
Mirrorban van egy epizód, a Sancho di
Pero, hogy élhetnénk-e teljesen
virtuális valóságban, és ez általában
mindig negatív vége van, mindig arra
jutunk, hogy szükség van a
virtuálitásból való kitörésre. Tehát az
emberek a a körülöttünk való környezetet
és a körülöttünk való más embereknek a a
fizikai jelenlétét
úgy tűnik valamiért jobban értékelik,
mint a mint a a digitális jelenlétet.
Még hogyha digitálisan is ismerkedsz meg
valakivel, előbb-utóbb élőben találkozni
szeretnétek. Tehát mindenképpen van
nekünk egy ilyen, nem is biztos, hogy
értjük értjük értjük ezt, de a
környezettel való interakcióra nekünk
szükségünk van.
És én úgy érzem, hogy a
a fizikai világban manifesztálódó
szépség az agyunkba talán egy más pályát
aktivált. Az másképp éljük meg, hogyha
lehull egy fehér egy levél a fáról is.
Az az gyönyörű, mintogyha
befejeződik egy film és ilyen nagy
katarzissal lesz vége. Mind a kettő úgy
érezzük, hogy ez szép, de a a fizikai az
talán talán más.
És
szerintem akkor Péter le ugyanazzal a
ugyanazzal a lendülettel, ahogy ő
lehetne
akármi, ami mondjuk fehér galéros munka,
ugyanazzal a lendülettel a az
elkövetkező világban, ami újra
visszanyik az a az elejére, talán
nyugodtabban lehet ő asztalos, vagy
nyugodtabban lehet vízgástszerelő,
mert talán amit meg tudna majd adni,
azért, mert ezek a szakmák talán akkor
nagyobb keresetnek fognak örvendeni,
Ezáltal egy
most jelenleg informatikushoz való
hasonló jövedelemhez, vagy talán
az életben kényelmi szinthez juthatná
őt. És neki ugyanakkor az élete talán
egyszerűbb lesz. Pontosan azért, ahogy
mondtad, hogy ők azért stresszelnek
nagyon sok mindenen, mert nagyon sok
információt kapnak, és ezt nem tudják
még a a 10 éves vagy 20 éves
élettapasztalatukkal nem tudják
elhelyezni, hogy melyik milyen milyen
dobozba milyen dobozba jár. De egy idő
után majd el fogják el fogják tudni
helyezni, és amikor rájönnek a a fizikai
dolgoknak, a megtapinthatóságnak a
kiteljesülési érményére, ami igazából
amitában mindenki
üldöz egy élete során, akkor nekik ez
egy rövidebb folyamat lesz, mert ők ők
nem kell átmenjenek az algoritmusnak a
megírásán, azt meg valakinek a
bemutatásán, hogy aztán később jöjjön a
a péld az én szakmom esetében a a
legszebb rész az, amikor
egy tele tele osztályteremnek, egy 100
emberrel tele osztályteremnek, vagy vagy
publikus előadóteremnek valamit
elmondasz, és akkor az emberek a
tapsolás is szép, de a amikor befejeztél
egy gondolatot, és nincsen taps, és
amikor teljesen csend van, az az talán
az én szakmában a legérdekesebb, vagy a
leg
több dopamint felszabadítással járó járó
élmény.
De amikor pontosan így amikor ezt a ezt
az asztalnak a tetejét megcsiszoltad és
akkor úgy a a a csiszológép úgy elhal,
és akkor csend van, lehet, hogy a ahhoz
nincsen szükség még 100 emberre. És
akkor ezek a kiteljesedési utak
szerintem a fizikai szakmáknál
gyorsabbak.
És ez szerintem meg fog változni a mai
világhoz képest, hogy újra úgy lesz
értékelve, ahogy az kell szerintem.
Tehát és akkor ezáltal még talán a a
társadalomnak a sarkosodására vagy az
ikkus kérdésre is visszatérhetünk, hogy
lehet, hogy automatikusan
ugye a az egy órás beszélgetés nélkül
hajlamosak vag voltunk egyből arra
válaszolni, hogy az AI felerősíti a
társadalomban levő különbségeket. De ezt
figyelembe véve pont ugyanúgy, ahogy a a
Cloud-nak elmondtuk a kontextust és most
figyelembe veszi a kontextust, most
másképpen válaszol. Lehet, hogy most azt
válaszolnánk, hogy pont hogy pont, hogy
kiegyenlíti.
>> Nagyon tetszik az az irány, amen
haladunk, és és egy nagyon mély válasz
volt a gyakorlatilag a könyvtárra
visszatérün.
>> De elfelejtettem a könyvtárral
válaszolni. Igen. Hogy a könyvnek, tehát
a az én kisfiamnak, az öt éves
kisfiamnak azt hisem, neked is talán
vannak hasonló korú gyerekeid.
A könyv nyilván a a rajzfilmet mindenki
szereti nézni, mert az egy kicsit olyan
saját milliőt kreál, de de a a fizikai
könyv, amit a kezébe tud venni, az az
egy olyan izgalommal jár, vagy a játékok
ugye a a kisgyerekek fizikai játékokkal
szeretnek szeretnek játszani. Nyilván
nekik az agyuk még nincsen kifejlődve,
de mindenképpen úgy néz ki, hogy van
valami biológiailag kódót. arra
szerettem volna visszajönni, ami nekünk
a fizikai világnak az érzékelését, a
tapintását
felsőbb lépcsőre helyezi, mint a a mint
az interakciókat. A digitális interakció
meg ahogy mondtad, a találkozás is van
valami a találkozásban, amit
alulértékeltünk eddig a a digitális
online kommunikáció által, de például a
covid alatt én azt hiszem, hogy
nagyon-nagyon sokan megcsömöröltek
ettől, hogy kilugozódtak a kapcsolatok,
amikor már valakit éveken keresztül
online látsz. Csak például az egyik
tapasztalatom a podcast sorozat során,
hogy azok az epizódok, amelyeket
távolról vettem fel, nem annyira
nézettek, mint amikor valaki itt van
személyesen,
>> és nem legtöbben hallgatják a podcastet,
nem nézik, nem nem az van, hogy a a
telefonjukon látják, de mégis érzik maga
maga a beszélgetésnek a tónusába, az
intenzitásába érződik, hogy most egy
teremben vagyunk, vagy pedig te valahol
egy pár 100á kilméterrel vagy akár
1000errel távolabb vagy. Valahol érezzük
azt a pár 100 milliszekundumos késést a
beszélgetésbe, és emiatt izgalmasabbá
válik ez a beszélgetés. Valami van a
találkozásban, ami számunkra fontos, és
talán a könyvtárhoz ezt tudnám mondani,
hogy hogy a a könyvtárhoz egy
találkozási pont is kell legyen. Olyan
emberek, akik hasonló beállítottságúak,
egy intellektuális beállít
beállítottságúak, találkoznak egy
helyen.
Még mindig nem tudtuk megnyugtatni
Pétert. Egy egy szinten még mélyebbre
szeretnék menni, mert tényleg a én
egyetértek, a világ szép. És van mit
gyönyörködjünk benne, és
megnyugodhatunk, és és a fizikai munka,
a a jól elvégzett munka utáni nap,
amikor lefekszünk, és amikor valamit
elkészítettünk, van benne egy
kielégülés, valami öröm, de ugyanígy a a
szoftver világban is van, csak nem
hasonló. Tehát amikor már éveken
keresztül valami absztrakt dolgon
dolgozol, és a végfelhasználót nem is
ismered, vagy esetleg pont, hogy a
problémákkal szembesülsz, mint az orvos,
hogy csak akkor látod a másik szemét,
hogyha probléma van, hogyha egy bug van
a szoftverben, ez nem nem adtja azt a
kielégülést, amikor az asztalos
elkészíti az asztalt, és megfogja és
utána aztán tovább adja. Szóval a
fizikai világ szép, de mondhatnám azt
Péternek, ahogy a van egy ilyen hang is
a társadalomban, hogy de hát nélküled is
szép. Ühüm.
>> Tehát rád nincs nagyon szükség. Nincs
nagyon szükség, mert nem vagy elég okos,
nem vagy elég művelt. Te mint ember nem
vagy elég értékes, mert ezt az asztalt
amúgy egy humanoid robot rakta össze
tizedannyiért, mert nem nincsenek
szakszervezetek és nincsenek
fizetett szabadnapok és nincsenek nincs
egészségügyi biztosítás. Szóval talán
jobb lenne Péter, hogyha nem is lennél.
És ez az életellenes hangulat azért nem,
tehát mondjam úgy, hogy létezik. Én
hallottam olyanokat, hogy jobb lenne,
hogyha már csak két milliárd ember
létezne a földön. Jobb lenne, mert mert
túl vagyunk népesedve, és hogy hogy
amúgy ez nem igazájelbe a hallgatóknak,
hogy hogy bár növekszik a népesség, ez
ez nem igaz, hogy túl vagyunk népesedve,
és hogy éhénységek lesznek emiatt. És ez
egy külön podcast adás, most belementem.
De miért van szükség Péterre? Mi az
emberi méltóságnak a a legitim alapja?
>> Jó, értem. Tehát
jól van, vessük ki a hálónkat bővebbre.
Akkor
abszolút egyetértek veled, hogy
kifejezetten az utóbbi
kettő évtizedben
nagyrészt
a
az amerikai kulturális nézet, és annak
szerintem az egész világra való
hatásait. Furcsa talán székelyféldről az
amerikai kulturális nézetről beszélni,
de a gyerkőcők a TikTokon ugyanazt
látják, mint a floridai vagy a
kaliforniai fiatalok, úgyhogy kell erről
beszélni.
Azok az az értékrendszer, amit a a
az amerikai kifejezetten hát mondhatjuk
itt liberálisnak, de itt nem igazán
vannak Amerikában nem ugyanazt jelenti,
mint itt, hanem mondjuk itt a szuper
progresszív Amerikában, hogy hívják
őket. Az a nézet az egy erősen
életellenes nézet, majdnem emberellenes
nézet.
És
nehéz azt mondani, hogy most akkor egy
amerikai filozófiai irányzat egy egy 15
éves székelföldi gyerekre hatással van,
de itt a a sok áttéten keresztül, hogy
hogyan lesz egy YouTube
videóklip elkészítve, hogyan lesz egy
egy TikTok videónak a végső üzenete
megfogalmazva,
ezek a milliárdnyi nagyon apró
impulzuson keresztül az jön végülis
Péterhez, hogy
a az emberi lét az egy az egy az egy
negatív dolog, vagy vagy túlnépesedés
van. Meg ugye ez az erős az erős
közösség versus individualizmus, amikor
az individualizmust az extrémre
csavarjuk, akkor jön ez, hogy én vagyok
itt a legfontosabb, és senki más
nem számít.
És ez ilyen furcsa, mert az erősi
individualizmus, ami mindenkinek azt az
üzenetet kellene közvetítse, hogy te
vagy a legfontosabb, hogyha mindenkinek
azt mondod, hogy te vagy a legfontosabb,
és teljesen szétesik a közösség. Én
nagyon sokat interakcionálok ázsiai
közösségekkel, akik ennek az ellentét
Korea ugye az egy kicsit olyan
kakuktojás meg japán ismerők, inkább az
amerikai kurzust követik.
Azáltal, hogy azt mondod, hogy a
közösségnek nincsen értelme, ez oda fog
lefordítani, hogy akkor a
párkapcsolatnak és magának a az elemi
közösségnek, a családnak sincsen akkora
értelme. Tehát egy
egy negatív marketinget kap az egész az
egész család. És nagyon-nagyon zavaró.
Én például próbálom
a deguglifyolás mellett, próbálok a a
hollywoodi film iparnak is próbálom.
Nyilván ez nagyon nehéz. Próbálom ennek
a limitációját is valamilyen szinten
művelni. Nagyon sok ugye a a érték a
hollywoodi filmiparból
félc családokból áll fel a főhősnek a a
az élete. Nyilván ez, ahogy mondtad, ez
egy másik podcast. Ö talán a
a nem a nem a nem a nem a kizsákmányoló,
hanem mondjuk a a a szerető apának a
képe kevésbé van jelen, mint az jelen
kellene legyen. Szerintem nyilván vannak
filmek, de amik most már sajnos már csak
kakuk tojások, és nem nem a mainstre,
amik amik ezt amik ezt erősítik. Úgyhogy
ez
ez mind-mind hatásol van Péternek a
gondolkodási világára. És akkor ezzel
ezzel ez ez erre ráépülve jönnek azok a
narratívák, hogy túlnépesedés van, mer
ott nyilván nincsen, mert aztán le fog
esni a népességörőrb szikláról 2070
után.
Alapvetően szerintem a felelősségre
vonatkoztatható vissza ez. Most ez egy
furcsa szó, majdnem el is felejtettük a
nyugat-európai és az észak-amerikai
társadalomban, hogy mi az, hogy
felelősség. Márpedig az azt jelenti,
hogy ha val, hogyha egy társadalom adott
neked valamit, akkor te valamilyen
szinten,
és ez furcsa, mert nyilván nem kell, de
az agyad úgy van összehuzalozva, hogy te
is jól éreznéd magad, hogyha visszaadnád
a közösségnek. És ugye mindenki a
sikeres emberek közül, mindenki arról
beszél, és nagyon nehéz ezt megérteni.
Talán el kell jutni abba a pozícióba,
hogy
a te a a az a kis kiteljesülés, amikor a
amikor elkészítjük az asztalt, az az
nagyszerű. De talán amikor a közösség
értékeli ezt, amikor elhoznak egy
turistacsoportot, hogy meglátogassák a
műhelyedet, ahogy elkészíted az asztalt,
ezzerszer akkora, vagy százszor akkora
kiteljesedés. Úgyhogy mindenképpen van
egy olyan narratív, ami szerintem
hiányzik, hogy a a közösséghez
tartozás felelősséggel is jár. És ez a
felelősség az az, hogy a közösséget úgy
tesszük jóbá, hogyha minden korosztály
jelen van. Ugyanúgy szükség van a
gyerekka kacajra, mint a mint a
nagyapónak a bölcseletére. Ö nem lehet
csak saját magunkra robotok által élni a
társadalomban, mert az oda fog vezetni,
hogy az agyunknak egy részét nem fogjuk
aktiválni, és az végül
tömeges depresszióhoz fog szerintem
vezetni. És ami nagyon érdekes, az az,
hogy mi most Csíkszerában vagyunk, és
annak ellenére, hogy a az utóbbi 35 év
narratívája minket folyamatosan
nyugat-európaiként
nyugatiként próbál beállítani, és mi is
nem keveset tettünk és pedáloztunk
azért, hogy ez így legyen,
ez nem éppen így van, mert mi
csíkszeriként
én, hogyha bárhol mozgok a világban, és
ez nagyon furcsa,
volt tehát hogyha hogyha én talál
találkozok valakivel, aki mondjuk
Belaruszból vagy Kazachstánból van. Én
úgy érzem, hogy azok a viccek, amiket
nevetünk, azok hasonlóbbak, mint mondjuk
egy némettel vagy egy ausztriival
egyre gyakrabban, ami talán a a sajnos
része, egy magyarországival.
Úgyhogy van meg ebben a régióban a
Kelet-Európában is nem szeretjük magukat
Kelet-Európának hívni, de a
kelet-európai régióban megvan az az
ázsiai energia, ami a közösséget helyezi
előtérbe.
Ezért is most már szerencsére próbálunk
egyre nagyobb családokat létrehozni itt,
mert úgy például Koreában, ami történik,
kies egy idő után, hogyha egy generáción
keresztül nagyon alacsony a szülési
ráta, kiesik a gyereknek a a
>> nem ne nem arra a gondolok, hanem az a
pozitív élmény, annak a szeretete, hogy
milyen szép egy egy fiatal család,
milyen szép egy játszót ír, amikor tele
van gyerekekkel, hogyha ezt nem látod,
akkor nem tudod, egy idő után már nem
tudsz rá á vonatkoztatni, hogy hú, ezt
így is lehet. És
most szerencsére szerintem itt
hát Székelyföldön talán Románia szerte
is ez a ez a legalább megállóban van ez
a ez a népességcsökkenési folyamat,
hátha meg fog hátha meg tudna fordulni.
Mindenképpen van egy szerintem egy új
lent a gyerekvállalásba.
De nem kell föltétlenül elbizakodni,
tehát folyamatosan kell azokat a a
különböző
kezdeményezéseket támogatni, amelyek a
közösségnek a a fontosságát teszi
előtérbe. És itt itt itt újra alá kell
húzom, hogy nem csak a közösséget, hanem
a családét. A könyvtárban kell legyen
olyan rész, ahol ami családoknak van.
Kell legyen nekünk olyan rendezvényünk,
ami kifejezetten családoknak van. Ez nem
azt jelenti, hogy kizárjuk a azokat,
akik úgy választották meg az életüket,
hogy ők nem családban gondolkodnak, de
kell legyen kifejezetten erre extra
energia fordítva, hogy a család az egy
szép és pozitív dolog, mert Ázsiában
nagyon sok ilyen van, és ez egy nagyon
pozitív
általános létezésben csapódik le.
E ez ez nagyon jó, amit mondtál, hogy a
felelősségvállalás az, ami egyedül
emberi, mert valójában a a gépeknél nem
létezik ez a fogalom. Most mi az, hogy a
chat GPT felelősséget vállal, hogyha
rossz választod, akkor lekapcsolom az
egyik szerverét, vagy tehát, hogy hogy
ez ez értelmezhetetlen a gépek esetében
az ember tud felelősséget vállalni és
Péter te vagy az, aki felelősség ez kell
legyen a következő generációnak az
üzenetünk, hogy Péter te vagy az, aki
felelősséget tudsz vállalni.
Vannak dolgok, amik el vannak romolva a
világban. Rengeteg szenvedés van,
rengeteg igazságtalanság. Fogj meg egy
dolgot, és javítsd meg. És és ez ad
értéket Péternek. Ez ad értéket a
következő generációnak. Ez ad értéket
nekem is. Birkózni valami olyan
problémával, amivel csak emberek
birkózhatnak, és használjunk fel
mindent. Tehát, hogy a a mesterséges
intelligencia, a gépek azok legyenek
eszközök a kezünkbe. Ne minket
irányítsanak, ne előttünk járjanak, és
mi csak kullogunk mögöttük. Hanem mögénk
kell utasítani, hogy ők segítsenek
minket, hogy mi elől tudjuk törni, úgy
mint a jég jégtörőhajó, ugy a törjük elő
magunk magunk előtt a jeget, és olyan
helyeket hódítsunk meg, amiket addig nem
tudtunk meghódítani, és tegyük a
világunkat jobbá, és ezt Péter ahhoz,
hogy ezt el tud érni, aranyeszközzé kell
váljá, alázatossá, fókuszáltá
és és fegyelmezetté kell váljál, és
egyszerre kell kalandban legyen részed,
és valamennyi biztonságban, mert a túl
sok sokkal nagy szétszaki, de így
gyakorlatilag ez az elhívás része, amit
amit láttok most így a jövőben, hogy el
kell hívni a fiatalokat, hogy ti nem
arra vagytok elhívva, hogy ilyen
universal basic incomeon már 20 évesen
nyugdíjasként viselkedjetek és és
biztonságban éljetek, és és védelemben,
hanem az emberben van valami huligánság,
ahogy mondtad, vagy valami olyan, ami
ami megszakítja a
>> a múltat, és valami újat hoz be. És
persze a múlt tradícióira építve, mert
ahogy mondtad, fontos számunkra a
tradíció, hogyan tudjuk megújítani ezt?
Ez a feladata a mostani jelenlevő
embereknek, hogy a a múlt halott
tradícióját, mert valójában akik
képviselték, azok mint halottak, azokat
leporolni és értékes hagyatékként méltó
helyre helyezni az életünkben, de
megújítsuk. És Péter emiatt kell
gyermeket vállalni, és emiatt érdemes
érdemes küzdeni és fejlődni, és tanulni
és a kényelmetlenséget és az
álmatlanságot, és a nehézséget vállalni
ezzel. Ez nekem nagyon fontos kérdés.
Azért is hoztam ezt így központi témába,
és azt hiszem, hogy ez is a csúcspontja
így a podcastünknek, hogy rengeteget
gondolkozok azon, hogyan tudom meg
kívántatni a gyermekeimmel, hogy
vállaljanak gyerekeket. annyi minden
bizonytalanságban, hogyha én
végigstresszelem a napjaimat, hogy mi
lesz a a munkahelyemmel, mi lesz a a
jövővel, mi lesz, és és nem mutatok be
nekik egy olyan példát, ahol megkívánják
tőlem a tanulást, megkívánják tőlem a
harcot, megkívánják tőlem azt, hogy
látják, hogy tényleg kapok ide egy-egy
balegyenest itt, ott, de mégis örömmel
tudok felkel, igazi örömmel, nem egy
ilyen műörömmel, hanem egy igazi örömmel
tudok kimenni és játszani velük. És
nehéz, az az igazság, nehéz, mert amikor
a fejem 8 óra munka után, vagy 10 óra
munka után tele van mindenfével, és jön
a kisfiam, hogy apu, apu nézd meg mit
rajzoltam, és nem tudom milyen legó
robot meg nem tudom micsoda,
>> és és nagyon nehéz fókuszálni, nehéz
nehéz figyelni, mert intenzívek a
gyerekek, egyszerűen nagyon-nagyon
intenzívek. Az aki nem vállal a
gyermeket, az nem tudja, hogy mennyire
intenzív. A legintenzívebb dolog, amit
láthat a a gyermeke, az aki folyamatosan
éhes és folyamatosan impulzusra vágyik
és a jelenlétre és a figyelemre. Ö
úgyhogy és mégis talán ez a legjobb
befektetés, azt látom, az életem legjobb
befektetései voltak így a gyermekeink.
>> Ezt ezt nyilván osztom ezt a véleményt.
Ugyanakkor szerintem az is fontos, hogy
vagy fontos elmondjuk, hogy a társadalom
a szülőktől
szerintem tudatlanul, de ahogy ahogy így
egyre egyre inkább így átváltozott a
társadalom, jelenleg a szülőktől többet
vár el talán, mint bármikor máshol a
történelem során. Tehát most nem jelenti
azt, hogy tehát nehéz szülőnek lenni.
Szerintem nehezebb, mint a szüleinkben
és még nehezebb, mint a nagyszülk
idejében. Nem tudok már annál távolabbra
látni. Valószínűleg volt olyan, amikor
talán még nehezebb volt, amikor ugye az
egzisztencia is kérdés volt, de de
pontosan azért, mert a közösségi
médiában nagyon sok
talán sokszor falcskép terjeng arról,
hogy mi az ideális szülő, és mindenki
ezt az ideált próbálja követni. Ezért
nagyon sokszor
próbálsz maximumon szülő lenni és
maximumon
alkalmazott vagy cégvezető lenni. És én
nagyon sokszor találkozok olyan
ismerősökkel, barátokkal, akik
akik néha úgy érzik, hogy azért ez túl
sok, átcsapnak a hullámok a fejük
fölött. De gyakorlatilag szerintem
ez egy jó dolog, mert ahogy ahogy
mondtad, hogyha az embereknek
tehát olyan furcsa, jobb az, mintogyha
fáradtnak érzed magad, miután elvégeztél
valamit, mintogyha
egész napéztél a kanapén, és nem
csináltál semmit. Kiteljesedettnek érz
érzed magad. Lehet, hogy nem volt
könnyebb, nem baj. De de az agyunk ezt
ezt a fajta ezt a fajta szerotonint vagy
dopamint jobban értékeli, mint
>> fáradtak leszünk, de csillogni fog a
szemünk.
>> Igen. Igen. És akkor
nincsen szerintem kellő
kellő úgymond ilyen ilyen glorifikáció,
ilen istenítés arra, hogyha hogyha
hogyha valaki keményen dolgozik és és jó
szülő. Tehát és ez Székelyföldön is
probléma. Például, hogyha valaki csak
szülő, hogyha hogyha nem dolgozik, hanem
full time szülő, nem viszonylunk kellő
alázattal szerintem nyilván ez gyakran a
nők esetében van, nem viszonylunk kellő
alázattal ahhoz, hogy az az mekkora
erőfejeztést igényel, hogy minden egyes
mért kérdésnél teljes mell bedobással
ott kell lenni és kell válaszolni. Tehát
itt itt itt van van azért egy ilyen egy
vödörnyi tisztelet, amit szerintem
muszáj lenne észrevenni. És ugyanakkor
legalább akkor alázattal kell
viszonyulni ahhoz, aki ahogy mondtad, a
nyolc órás átdolgozott műszak után
ugyanúgy próbál. Lehet, hogy nem
fizikailag már nem képes ott lenni
100%-ban, de itt a a ugye a az energia,
az effort, a befektetett energia a
lényeg, hogyha próbál ott lenni, az
mindenképpen egy tisztelendő dolog.
Tehát nem kell féljünk, menjünk az úton
és megveregessük egymásnak a vállát,
hogy Szabolcs, ügyes, ügyes gyermek
vagy, milyen szép gyerekeket nevelz,
hogy hogy éled az életedet. Ez egy olyan
dolog, amire Péter például aspirálhatna.
Tehát egymásból is képesek vagyunk
pozitív példákat generálni és
ebből én nem látok eleget szerintem.
Székely föld zárszóként egy bőmondatot
kérlek mesélj a családodról.
A van
egy két éves kislánom, kislányom, Zéna
és egy négy és fél éves fiam Kamil,
illetve feleségem Mazd, ő Jordán.
És minden évben
ugye mi Angliában lakunk, járnak mind a
ketten óvodába vagy bölcsödébe, ahogy
ahogy itthon hívnánk, ott angolul
beszélnek, és akkor mind a ketten
próbáljuk a saját nyelvünket
betartani. Ugye újra elég sok
erőfesztésbe kerül, de az annál
gyönyörűbb dolog nincsen, mint amikor
egy mondaton belül, hogyha beszélő
partnert változtat a gyerek, akkor ő
automatikusan átváltja a a nyelvet.
Tehát, hogy újra ugyanúgy, ahogy amikor
én látom, hogy a Cloud milyen szépen
megold egy problémát, újra ugyanúgy
tudom látni, hogy hát erre az emberi agy
is képes, csak meg kell teremtsük azt a
azt a kontextust. Úgyhogy én magyarul
beszélek velük, és a feleségem arabul
beszél a a gyerekeimvel, és akkor minden
évben próbálunk itt tölteni nyáron is
egy hónapot, meg télen is egy hónapot,
és ugyanúgy Jordániában is, nyáron is,
illetve tavasszal is egy
>> mennyire mennyire keverednek ezek a
nyelvek a fejük? egyáltalán nem
keverednek. Tehát ez nagyon-nagyon
érdekes. Van arra
így más más ilyen billing vagy thrilling
ismerőseimtől van arra példa, hogy
később, tehát ilyen hét főleg az iskola
idejében, ilyen hét-nyolc évesen
lesz egy domináns nyelv, de általában a
domináns nyelv a harmadik nyelv szokott
lenni, az angol, de nem a szülőknek a
nyelve, hanem hanem a harmadik nyelv. De
jelenleg amit én észreveszek a fejében,
abszolút nem keveredik.
>> Nagyon látom, hogy azért dolgoznak a
fogaskerekek, tehát
pici fegyelemmel van, amikor neki
könnyebb lenne elmondani egy adott
nyelven vagy egy másik nyelven, de úgy
rá kellett vezessük az évek során, hogy
nem apuval csak ilyen nyelven beszélünk,
és anyuval csak ilyen nyelven beszélünk.
És akkor így automatikusan megszokja
nyilván egy idő után, és úgy látod, hogy
ezt most neki extra erőfeszítés lesz
elmondani ezen a nyelven, mert tudná a
másik szót kettő másik nyelven
egyszerűben, és hogy úgy gondolkodik, de
de végül csak ráveszi magát, csak
előhúzza abból a dobozból és
hát ez én remélni tudom, hogy ez nyilván
meg van kutatás is, am nyilván, amelyik
biz amelyik ezt alátámasztja, hogy ez ez
hosszú távon azért jó dolog, hogyha
hogyha több nyelvű
az ember. Tehát arra számít az, hogy
amikor felnőnek, akkor az angolt
anyanyelvi szinten fogják majd beszélni,
és közel anyanyelvi szinten a magyart és
az arabot.
>> Hát én arra számítanék, hogy ha mind a
hármat anyanyelvi szinten beszélnék, de
valószínűleg ez lesz, amit ez lesz, amit
te mondasz.
>> Lénes, egy iszonyatosan izgalmas
beszélgetés volt. Köszönöm szépen, hogy
itt voltál. Remélem, hogy a hallgatóknak
is hasonlóképpen fog tetszeni, de ez
egyik legjobb epizód volt. És mikor
indultsz vissza Angliába? Hát én
köszönöm szépen a meghívást, és még van
egy pár napom, aztán aztán most itt
voltunk egy itt voltunk ugye egy pár
hetet. Most akkor megyünk Jordániába egy
pár hetet, és aztán ezek az angolok,
ezek nagyon nem tudom, ilyen másképpen
állnak hozzá az iskolához. Ők
beleintegráltak két óvodaévet az
iskolába, úgyhogy az iskola az négyes-öt
éves kor között kezdődik. És az első két
év az ilyen hát mint nálunk volt a a
zérós csoport, ilyen ilyen óvoda
>> úgyhogy úgyhogy Kamil szeptembertől megy
iskolába, úgyhogy ez eg ez lesz nekünk
most a nagy változás.
>> Köszönöm szépen, hogy itt voltás, jó
utat nektek. Köszi szépen.